très bien voilà nous attendons que les
journées et photographes en tout cas
quitte la salle
oui
bien merci merci mes chers collègues
donc nous poursuivons nos travaux avec
l'audition du professeur didier raoult
et de l'institut hospitalo
universitaires en maladies infectieuses
de marseille comme il se doit je
voudrais présente les excuses d'alain
milon président de la commission et de
la commission en enquête qui est retenu
sur son département
voilà rappelé que le bureau de notre
commission denquête avait initialement
conçu cette audition sur la forme de
tables rondes ainsi que je l'évoquais ce
matin alors que dans d'autres pays la
réponse à la crise a été incarné par un
personnage politique un médecin ou un
chercheur qui a réussi à entraîner la
population derrière ces recommandations
nous avons assisté en france à des
propos discordants qui ont beaucoup nui
au niveau de confiance de la population
à propos d'un virus inconnu les attentes
dans la science était très élevé certes
la controverse est normale elle fait
avancer la science
mais quand elle s'étale aussi largement
dans les médias elle fait plutôt
augmenter le niveau d'inquiétude
nous avions donc souhaité demander des
explications aux scientifiques comme
certains n'ont pas manqué de nous le
rappeler mais nous ne lire nous aurions
pas nous ne sommes pas des scientifiques
de haut niveau et ce n'est pas une
conversation scientifique
ce n'est pas à une conversation
scientifiques que nous convions nos
intervenants nous représentons des
personnes qui dans leur immense majorité
ne le sont pas davantage c'est pourquoi
nous aurions préféré et préférait éviter
les monologues sans contradictoires
toutefois ainsi que vous l'avez rappelé
lors de votre audition à l'assemblée
professeur à propos du conseil
scientifique
vous n'êtes pas arriver à vous parler et
il nous est apparu que vous ne
parviendrez pas davantage dans cette
enceinte à parler en toute sérénité
cette audition a pour objet la recherche
les tests et les traitements elle
abordera notamment la méthodologie
applicable aux essais cliniques
les orientations privilégiées en france
au vu de la comparaison entre discovery
et recovery
les résultats ainsi que la question des
publications ou d annonce précoce dans
la crise
donc je vais demander aux professeurs
out de présenter brièvement ses
principaux messages en 10 15 minutes
parce que les messages sont importants
et vous ne manquerez pas bien sûr de
nous alimenter par voie écrite comme
vous l'avait déjà fait à différentes
occasions je demanderai ensuite chacun
des des rapporteurs d'intervenir et
ensuite ce seront nos des questions de
nos commissaires que nous regroupons
voilà alors avant c'est une commission
denquête donc je vais procéder à la
demande de deux prêté serment rappeler
que tout propos mensongers et punis
d'une peine pouvant aller jusqu'à cinq
ans d'emprisonnement et de 75000 euros
d'amendé
donc professeur didier raoult ait prêté
serment de dire la vérité rien que la
vérité levé la main droite et dit je le
jure je jure merci bonjour appelle bien
sûr comme à chaque fois il est de mon
devoir que le port du masque est
obligatoire
je vous demande la plus grande vigilance
par le pour le garder tout au long des
heures de ses auditions de cet après
midi merci donc sans plus tarder écoutez
je vous cède la parole
je vous remercie et d'ailleurs je
voudrais profiter de cette offre merci
de m'inviter ici de cette occasion dans
lequel vous m'avez demandé de juré de
dire toute la vérité
pour vous expliquer pourquoi je ne peux
pas me retrouver à discuter avec des
gens qui font une tribune en disant que
je frotte dès que je triche en mettant
leurs noms et ensuite faire une
discussion avec ya une limite c'est plus
des discussions scientifiques en a
d'autres qui ont porté plainte auprès de
moi auprès du conseil de l'ordre et vous
comprendrez bien que mal limite c'est
une
les limites à la convivialité je n'aime
pas qu'on insulte je n'aime pas qu'on
porte plainte contre moi et qu'apprendre
demande de débattre en toute sérénité
je le fais pas et donc je vous le dis
très solennellement et après avoir juré
de dire la vérité je n'ai jamais fraudé
de ma vie j'ai écrit 3500 publications
internationales
je n'en ai jamais rétracté aucune alors
bien entendu sur 3500 il y a eu des
erreurs qui sont passés pour l'instant
il ya une fille qui me traquent la une
chasseuse de têtes depuis que je suis
célèbre qui a réussi à trouver cinq
erreurs sur 3500 il y en a probablement
beaucoup plus que ça j'estime qu'il ya
entre 2 et 4 % d'erreurs dans les
papiers que j'ai fait et donc je ne
serais pas étonné qu'on trouve d'autres
erreurs mais je dois vous dire que je
suis qu'un pauvre humain que je fais des
erreurs comme tout le monde mais de
m'accuser sur une tribune officiellement
de fraude de mettre son nom là dessus et
et de penser que j'aurais débattre avec
c'est au dessus de mes forces et je vous
demande de pardonner de ne pas avoir la
force de discuter sereinement avec des
gens qui m'insultent je ferai pas je
ferai jamais bien si vous si j'ai
quelques messages à passer dans cette
affaire c'est effectivement si vous
voulez la chose qui me frappe le plus
depuis le début et qui est lié au fait
qu'il manque quelque chose dans mon la
forme de mon cerveau je suis absolument
incapable de mesurer la dimension
symbolique des choses c'est pas ce qui
s'est passé n'est pas normal on n'est
plus en train de parler de chimie ou de
malades ou de médicaments on est en
train de parler de quelque chose qui est
déconnecté de ce que moi je connais moi
je suis un être très pragmatique et
pratique il ya toujours eu dans la
séance une grande différence entre
l'empirisme d'un côté c'est à dire
l'observation des phénomènes et leur
description si vous voulez d'autre part
les théories déductive et spéculative
donc dont je ne suis pas à un praticien
d'accord mais si vous voulez ce qui
s'est passé dans cette situation est
absolument inouïe pour moi et pas que
pour moi ça marquera tout
l'épistémologie l'histoire des sciences
c'est à dire que un des deux médicaments
les plus prescrits au monde ait pu être
considéré comme étant un truc qui tue et
10 % des gens est quelque chose qui
montre qu'il y avait une déconnexion
entre la perception de ce qui est
l'hydrochlorothiazide si vous voulez de
la chimie de la molécule qui a été
utilisé ces problèmes en deux milliards
de personnes
donc il y a quelque chose que je ne
comprends pas auquel je ne suis pas
censé pas de maintenant je me rends
compte que je ne comprends pas bien les
données symbolique si vous voulez c'est
comme ça et donc je suis
extraordinairement surprise l'ampleur
qu'a pris cette chose est immédiatement
c'est d'ailleurs dès que mon premier
papier a été envoyée la chasseuse de
têtes l'a fait dire que j'avais des
conflits d'intérêts etc sanofi ce qui
est complètement idiot je fais des
essais thérapeutiques pour personne ça
fait 25 ans que je suis contre je fais
pas la deuxième chose est la demande
elle a fait de confirmer elle nous a
fait faire envoyer au journal qui
menaçaient de l'enlever cet article qui
est devenu le plus cité de toute la
littérature soit la thérapeutique
bucovine 19 sites et 2400 fois en dix
ans que je n'avais pas eu les
autorisations ge a pas eu de cdp et la
troisième chose
un déluge des gens qui sont des
maniaques de méthodologie je ne pouvais
pas imaginer qu'en envoyant un papier
comme ça comme j'en ai envoyé tellement
dans ma vie ceux ci allaient faire une
espèce de folie mondiale et donc toutes
les explications qu'on pourra donner ce
sont pas inintéressantes c'est le temps
qui triera pour comprendre ce qui se
passe moi personnellement je ne
comprends pas ça ne fait pas partie de
ce que je suis capable de comprendre
parce que il me manque une case sur la
signification symbolique des choses
peut-être pas que symbolique mais en
tout cas c'est pas mon problème donc
nous on a continué à faire je pensais
depuis longtemps
en réalité depuis plus de vingt ans je
pensais qu'il fallait faire comme pour
les centres anticancéreux des centres de
lutte pour les maladies infectieuses qui
comprenait tous les patients le
laboratoire la recherche
petit à petit je les écris à 20 ans
quand j'étais le conseiller de
de mattei et de l'améliorer où j'ai
rencontré d'ailleurs gilles bloch d'un
petit connaissez parfaitement mes
projets puisqu'il n'est entré au cabinet
de 1 et directeur l'insee il était
rentré au cabinet de mme à l'améliorer
en dix ans pour faire face à des
situations comme celle-là il faut avoir
des structures organisées dans lequel on
fasse tout dentelle y ait des gens
qu'ils soient compétents à tous les
domaines et à tous les niveaux de
manière à pouvoir répondre à toutes les
questions au fur et à mesure et pas
avoir un ordre dispersé donc l' ordre
dispersé monsieur le sénateur je savais
qu'il allait arriver
c'est pas moi qui les disperser nous
étions en ordre dispersé et d'une
manière très singulière donc pour pas
que vous croyez que je considère qu'à
paris plus rien est organisée c'est pas
vrai en neurologie si quelqu'un avait un
problème dans ma famille je l'enverrai à
la pitié parce qu'il ya un centre de
neurologique est colossal s'il y avait
quelqu'un qui est un problème génétique
que je l'enverrai sûrement à necker et
imagine c'est pas de problème avec ça
mais en maladies infectieuses
ici on a détruit l'organisation des
maladies infectieuses
elle n'existe plus et donc si vous
retrouvez avec un port marseillais en
train de vous dire ce qu'ils pensent
c'est parce qu'il ya une destruction
physique de l'organisation des maladies
infectieuses qui était à l'hôpital
claude bernard là les forces de maladies
infectieuses l'institut de veille
sanitaire a été mis à saint maurice
alors que c'était une vraie bonne idée
moi j'avais écrit à l'époque de le
mettre à côté de pasteur ou de maître -
des antennes de pasteur à côté vous
voyez le les hôpitaux de malik
spécialisé en maladies infectieuses ont
été dispersées dans toute la ville et
donc vous n'avez pas de cendres vous
n'avez pas de pardonnez moi je vis vous
n'avez pas de patron et si de maladies
infectieuses voulait pas alors que vous
l'aviez ya 30 ans vous n'avez pas vous
avez des patrons dans les autres
domaines vous avez des gens qui sont des
leaders dans les autres domaines dans ce
domaine là vous n'avez pas de leader
vous n'avez plus de leaders
microbiologie celui qui était le
meilleur a été tellement dégoûté seul
hic est parti en suisse
d'accord donc vous avez il ya un
problème ici avec les maladies
infectieuses
un véritable problème d'évolution
la citation qui fait des choses
absolument remarquable s'est éloigné
petit à petit avec le temps de la
pratique les maladies infectieuses à
l'hôpital pasteur
quand j'étais jeune je faisais tous les
diagnostics l'institut pasteur
l'épidémiologie partout à la sécu
personnes petit à petit cette partie là
a disparu pour être remplacé par par des
parrains une recherche fondamentale
beaucoup en neurosciences sont parmi les
meilleurs du monde
donc je vais pas une critique de la
qualité de ce qui se passe il ya une
désorganisation que les une
désorganisation de ce pays et qui se
voit ici pour ce sujet là je dis pas que
c'est vrai pour d'autres
si je trouve que bull pour la
microchirurgie je pense que j'en
strasbourg sans le dire ce que je pense
mais globalement c'est ce que je perçois
j'ai toujours pensé que j'ai pas la
chirurgie cardiaque à paris et
merveilleuse et elle continue à la
georges pompidou c'est pas il y a un
problème d'organisation de fonds et
celui des maladies infectieuses vous
savez que de gaulle avait répondu à la
cancérologie en disant écoutez on va
faire des centres anticancéreux dont qui
regroupe à la fois la radiothérapie la
chimiothérapie la chirurgie la médecine
il marche de manière inégale mais ils
ont joué un rôle très important
là aussi en cancérologie l'institut
gustave roussy
c'est une chose extraordinaire ça les
meilleurs sans trop de monde
d'immunologie de cancérologie donc c'est
pas la question
la question c'est que ce domaine n'est
pas organisé et que donc il ne peut
connaître des discordances moi j'ai
proposé de faire créer cette centre de
la nature de celui que j'ai fini par
réussir à construire à marseille dans
pays de manière à mailler le pays pour
pouvoir faire face à des crises
sanitaires qui n'arrêteront pas et notre
susceptibilité dans notre civilisation
aux crises sanitaires est très très
importante très très vive elle peut
désorganiser complètement la société si
nous ne sommes pas armés pour lutter
contre ces cellules sanitaire voilà donc
le sens général de ce que je voulais
dire et puis ensuite on rentre dans le
détail de ce que vous voudrez t merci
pour cette représentation de
l'infectiologie en france donc nous
allons rentrer dans le vif du sujet je
passe parole à catherine des roches
merci monsieur le président pensait pas
que les questions à l'adresse ayant fait
tomber mon chevalet
donc merci au professeur raoul de nous
avoir déjà donné des réponses à nos
questions très en amont pour nous les
rapporteurs de de cette audition ce qui
a permis de de travail et les réponses
et est aussi de pouvoir compléter
puisqu'on avait fait une audition dans
le cadre des commissions des affaires
sociales que je pilotais comme
rapporteur de la branche maladie ou vous
avez entendu des gens n'ont pas en
public mais où nous avions déjà balayé
un peu d'aidé sujet qui correspondait
l'état de la situation au moins deux au
moins demain quand nous l'avions nous
l'avions fait moi j'avais plusieurs
questions la première qui est plus
d'ordre pratico pratique c'est celle du
parcours du patient
qu'est-ce qui depuis le début de la de
l'évolution de l'épidémie
comment est-elle parcours du patient en
février ou au début vous avez vu arriver
les premiers patients dans votre
institut quel était le parcours du
patient test traitement isolement est ce
qu'il s'est modifiée au fil du temps et
qu'elle est aujourd'hui le parcours d'un
patient qui vient qui vient vous
consulté à l'institut un institut
marseillais le deuxième point c'est
c'est quelque chose que j'ai posée déjà
ce matin au professeur delfraissy
même si lui n'est venu en fonction que
le 11 mars mais lorsque fin janvier la
ministre de la santé nous dit au vu de
vraisemblablement de modélisation de
l'inserm
il ya peu de risque que le virus arrive
arrive chez nous
bon professeur de français nous a dit
qu'à l'époque il s'intéresse à mouler
nouveau sujet mais que en effet dès la
mi-février lui même avait senti quelque
chose se passait quel est votre avis sur
cette ces modélisations qu'on peut faire
dire cela la ministre de la santé de
l'époque
comment l'inserm a travaillé pour
arriver à ces conclusions si ce sont ces
conclusions qui ont été à l'origine de
de la vie et vous comment au niveau de
votre institut et de votre habitude de
ces maladies infectieuses même si là on
était sur un nouveau virus vous quels
étaient les alertes que vous aviez sur
quoi vous basez pour pour avoir avoir ce
degré de connaissance qu'apparemment les
autorités n'avaient pas ça c'est le
premier point
la deuxième question c'est sur les les
essais cliniques
c'est une question que j'ai évoqué ce
matin avec le professeur delfraissy
également c'était dans ces périodes de
crise sanitaire ou où les équipes
soignantes voit arriver des patients bon
pour certains en consultation mais pour
d'autres en réanimation ou en
hospitalisation et où il ya le besoin
d'apporter une réponse rapide et
thérapeutique aux malades
comment que ça peut se concilier avec
cette exigence d'essais randomisés de
travaux scientifiques robuste pour voir
l'efficacité du traitement
mais s'il n'y a pas pour tous ces
patients qui ne rentreraient pas dans
les études ou dans les essais avec un
médicament testé
est-ce qu'il ya pas une perte de chance
pour tous ceux qui ne rentrent pas
danser dans ces cases là bon vous nous
avez dans la note
donnez votre avis un peu sur ces essais
les essais randomisés tels qu'ils sont
et pas forcément adapté à la situation
pandémique telle qu'elle était donc
j'aimerais aussi vous entendre dessus
une question plus que plus large qui est
peut-être pas celles centrées sur la
commission denquête mais qui nous
intéresse au sein des commissions des
affaires sociales puisqu'on avait fait
un rapport sur l'accès à l'innovation et
notamment sur les essais
ligny le comité de protection des
personnes et j'aimerais avoir votre
façon assez rapide
votre avis en effet ce que vous nous
avez dit un peu dans la note mais
résumer sur comment vous voyez-vous les
comités de protection des personnes qui
étaient au départ de protée des comités
de protection des personnes éthiques
et qu'est ce qui a pu faire que là on
est allé assez vite sur certains essais
et que et qu'habituellement on n'y
arrive pas merci vous répondait
directement professeur à chacun chacune
des rapporteurs sur le bouton rouge
voilà c'est la manière dont nous
travaillons nous comme je voulais dit je
ne suis pas un homme de spéculations
donc je suis à très empirique est très
pratique pragmatique c'est la nature
elle me réserve de très bonnes surprises
je serais content de ce qu'on a pu
trouver je pense que l'on peut découvrir
d'ailleurs que par l'observation et
l'empirisme où on peut confirmer par les
techniques méthodologiques mais on peut
pas découvrir comme ça ça fait l'objet
de grands grands débats épistémologiques
donc la manière dont nous travaillons
d'abord c'est que nous lisons toute la
littérature et donc si vous voulez moi
j'ai été frappée du fait
si vous voyez le staff que nous avons
donc il ya une vingtaine de gens qui
sont au niveau professeurs ou juste en
dessous si travailler ensemble chacun
avec beaucoup de domaines c'est pour ça
que je crois ce que j'appelle les mid
recherche et non pas au réseau je crois
au nil recherche et on se voit tous les
jours tous les jours tous les jours à 8
heures du matin et on a un pharmacien
qui nous fait vous avez vu vous voyez
les applications de la mm qu'est ce qui
est vraiment est ce que vraiment on
applique là et même quand on est médecin
et la réponse c'est non
deuxièmement on a une spécialiste
d'hématologie co régulation qui fait la
bibliographie des de stomatologie
coagulation on a un super immunologie ce
qui était un ancien directeur des
sciences de la vie du cnrs qui fouillent
vraiment au niveau moléculaire sur la
physiopathologie on a un chimiste
bien sûr on a des infectiologues
virologues microbiologiste et chacun
nous des épidémiologistes de très très
haut niveau
dont celui qui a fait toutes les
enquêtes sur le charles de gaulle dont
je vous reparlerai qui font un travail
de fond sur le suivi permanent de la
bibliographie sur ces domaines et à
chaque fois qu'on a une question
quelqu'un creuse comme un fou pour en
tirer quelque chose
ce qui veut dire je vous en ai la liste
qu'on a déjà fait 54 publications
internationales qui sont ou publiez vous
acceptez ou en prêt trink donc quand on
s'est retrouvé face à la situation on a
fait comme d'habitude c'est à dire qu'on
a lu tout ce qu'avait fait les seuls
sachant qu'ils étaient le chinois et on
a regardé
qu'est ce qu'ils font et qu'est ce
qu'ils disent et puis on a regardé
qu'est ce qui se passe avec les autres
coronavirus et qu'est ce qui s'est passé
avec le premier épisode de sarce et au
début moi je vous assure j'ai téléphoné
tout de suite au ministère pour dire
écoutez voilà les médicaments qui marche
sur le sar seul 1 pourquoi on regarde
pas le targue aussi qui est un anti
staphylococcique qui est générique et
qui coûtent rien qui a été utilisé dans
le sahara un en corée qui a même eu un
brevet un moment qui a été déposé pour
le traitement du sahara avec sa deuxième
dans la chloroquine qui avait été montée
je rappelle qu'il faut si maintenant on
revient en arrière mais à l'époque il
est le traitement du sart et donc les
premiers résultats qui sont venues de
chine
une vie trop publié nordin un des
articles du groupe de journaux celle ce
qu'ils sont très bons journaux c'était
écouter les deux médicaments qui marche
de la chloroquine exotiques login d'une
part et d'autre part leur ai dit c'est
dire si lui n'étaient pas disponibles
sauf à avoir des accords avec gilead ou
à travailler sur des essais dans le
cadre de ce que voulait faire gilad que
nous voulions pas faire donc nous peu de
temps après les chinois ont commencé à
dire écoutez on a de manière
préliminaire nos premiers résultats il
ya 100 malades qu'on a traitées on voit
une amélioration clinique radiologique
et sur le portage général c'est ça qu'on
a fait c'est à dire qu'on si vous voulez
le l'idée quand vous dire que le risque
de certains médicaments vont se dérouler
en france ces cds qui n'a pas lieu
c'est une pandémie ça se déroule partout
il ya tout le monde a une expérience
tout le monde a quelque chose à dire et
donc on doit regarder les premiers qui
ont subi le flux pour voir déjà il avait
des crimes quantité de choses dont nous
y compris des choses qu'on a découvert
un peu plus tardivement comme parce que
ce qu'ils appelaient les l'hypoxie
heureuse voulait c'est-à-dire le fait
qu' il n'y avait pas les signes
respiratoires qu'on a d'habitude dans
les pneumonies et donc ça c'est la
première chose
la deuxième chose c'est que dès qu'on a
eu des cas on s'est mis à l' d'abord
tout de suite et je réponds à quelqu'un
qui me demander pourquoi il ya une telle
la tels délais dans la mise en place des
tests nous les tests dès que le génome a
été publié trois jours appelé avons
commandé les amorces pc donc l'idée une
des raisons du retard c'est qu'il y
avait ce que j'ai eu l'occasion
d'expliquer assemblée nationale c'est
qu'il y avait dans l'esprit des gens du
ministère qu'il y avait des centres
nationaux de référence quitte ce qui est
un rêve parce qu'il peut pas être un
centre national de référence pour le
mahdi qui n'existe pas c'est pas
possible pas de centres nationaux de
référence et des gens qu'ils aient moi
je suis venu money les gens qui
faisaient les coronavirus c'est pas eu
du tout d'ailleurs c'est quelqu'un qui
est à caen d'accord donc c'est les gens
se sont dit mais c'est nous les centres
nationaux de référence est donc au début
de ces discussions on me disait écouter
non mais il faut les du cas positifs
faut que vous les envoyer au centre
national de référence mais tout le monde
avec des séquences à sont là on avait le
génome qui avait publié chinois trois
jours après et nous on avait commandé
les les allemandes qui va extrêmement
vite
brillantissime hambourg à a tout de
suite dit tout et voilà moi j'ai testé
une qpcr donc on avait nous sélectionné
trois gènes qu'on avait commandé pour
qu'elle en avait commandé les témoins
positif de on a commandé les 2,2 des
allemands et puis ensuite quand pasteur
à présent à publier ça on april et c'est
en a pris tout ce qui existe et puis on
va tester on a regardé ce qui est bien
d'ailleurs pas ce que tu entends avec la
paix certes peut-être une question qui
reviendra parfois il ya des
contaminations qui sont le pca il faut
toujours avoir une deuxième cache est
alors une troisième pour être sûr de
confirmer les cas qui sont positifs pour
pas raconter des choses qui sont fausses
parce que il n'ya pas de laboratoire
dans lequel ça n'arrive pas qu'il ya une
contamination
c'est pas vrai ap cr c'est comme ça donc
si vous voulez le la manière dont nous
avons réagi nous si on regarde ce que
fait tout le monde ou fait je m'excuse
de cet anglicisme du match marking c'est
à dire qu'on regarde ce qu'ils savent
faire
on fait pareil en les imitent mais c'est
comme ça que la séance avance 9 fois sur
10 bases notre vie à imiter ceux qui ont
lu la première expérience on fait pareil
donc on a au début on a fait pareil très
rapidement fait rapidement on a vu qu'on
n'était pas sur la même longueur d'onde
parce que chaque fois qu'on parlait de
cette maladie on nous parlait décès et
de et de cpp donc savoir s'il fallait
les gens qui étaient contagieux leurs
maîtres alors faire un prélèvement
rhinopharyngé quand tombé des nues
qu'est ce que vous nous raconter c'est
les gens ils sont revenus pour savoir
s'il avait ça on va pas faire signe à
taper leur disons qu'ils sont d'accord
pour qu'on les tests pour savoir s'ils
ont le virus
soyez donc on était pape depuis le début
on n'est pas branché sur même il ya
quelque chose qui m'échappe je suis pas
branché c'était donc je les voyais pas
comme des sujets d'essai vous le dit pas
et donc je les vois toujours pas comme
des sujets décès et j'ai suivi au fur à
mesure qu'il y avait des données qui
arrive et on les a suivis
le premier patient qu'on a eu le
deuxième arrêté c'est sa femme qui était
la première belle le premier patient
qu'on a eu et était quelqu'un qui qui
nous a qui nous a parlé de son anneau
demi si vous voulez traiter un sujet sur
lequel ont travaillé pour essayer
d'identifier quelles étaient les causes
d'infections respiratoires y être un
virus qui est parent fleurs et 3 qui
donne des ados demi au printemps la
noémie saisonnière c'est par un influent
et 3 donc ça nous intéresse
la note b donc on a repéré l'anneau demi
mais si vous ne la cherchez pas et
maintenant on sait qu'il ya 60% des gens
mais les gens n'ont pas observé ça donc
cette phase d'observations empiriques et
de lecture de la delà de la littérature
vous voyez bien que dans les faits
discours je ris comme ça je ne parle pas
de pardon recovery désengage du pas du
mal des français ils n'ont pas mis ce
critère clinique en disant on peut faire
du diagnostic clinique d'une maladie
infectieuse qui est pas frais il faut
faire des tests biologiques et donc ils
ont publié ça donc il ya quand même des
gens qui ont publié des séries qui
servent actuellement à réfléchir chez
des gens qui n'ont pas eu de
confirmation diagnostic et même
l'élément clé
le plus déterminant de tous il ne
connaissait pas qui était la nauze me
aggasy d'accord qui a été connue
ultérieurement et nous je vous assure
vous fait un tri avec la nauze me aggasy
qu'il était incroyablement fonctionnel
ça marche très très bien on l'a testé
après en particulier en a testé dans le
dans le personnel de soins si vous
voulez et là on a pu les interroger
avant de savoir s'il avait été
contaminée pas donc il ya une vraie
contre andorre savoir très très bien
pour les gens qui ont moins de 60 ans et
c'est un test merveilleux de deux
d'efficacité donc voilà ce qu'on a fait
et au fur à mesure que le savoir s'est
accumulée bien entendu on a changé
on s'est rendu compte au bout d'un
certain moment qui avait pas ce que
c'était mal décrit au départ thierry les
troubles de la coagulation très
important on a commencé c'est d'abord
les réanimateurs qui n'ont vu puis
ensuite nous on s'est rapidement mis à
antico réguler les gens quand on s'est
rendu compte que les marqueurs de la
coagulation étaient des marqueurs de
pronostics extrêmement important après
il ya eu les premiers travaux qui sont
sortis de chine encore sur les autopsies
qui montrait que ce qu'on prenait
souvent pour des pneus open peut être
des pneumonies en réalité c'était
embolie pulmonaire multiples et que
c'était des lésions d'infarctus du
poumon et non pas de pneumonie ce que
l'on voyait les chinois avaient publié
aussi qu'il fallait faire des scanners
low dose sur lequel je me suis déjà
prononcé je pense qu'on a beaucoup de
retard
ça fait partie des projets de nouveaux
gouvernements de d'acheter d'augmenter
de l'équipement on a besoin de plus
beaucoup plus de scanner un
sous-équipement absolument terrible dans
ce pays de scanners pour remplacer les
radios thorax par les scanners low dose
à terme les chinois avaient publié que
il y avait au moins la moitié des gens
qui étaient dix à symptomatique ce qui
est une erreur c'est à dire sans fil
lennik identifiable en particulier
respiratoires vous voulez qu'il y avait
des lésions pulmonaires au scanner on a
confirmé sa d'accord donc ça veut dire
bien sûr la prise en charge à 100 arrêt
changé puisque quand vous avez des gens
qui dit est-ce qu'il faut tester les
gens asymptomatiques mais
asymptomatiques savez de quel point de
vue est-ce que c'est asymptomatiques
parce que vous les gens ne sont pas
essoufflé apparemment ou est ce que vous
regardez la saturation en oxygène ce
qu'on fait systématiquement est-ce que
vous
haarde et les scanners et donc vous ne
voyez pas la même chose bien entendu de
la manière dont vous regardez les gens
va pas vous dire donc si vous les
considérez comme la grippe
si vous voulez donc la déduction en fait
c'est comme la grippe c'est pas vrai
c'était une autre maladie et pour le
savoir il faut prendre le temps il faut
les regarder quand il faut commencer on
les examine ne regarde regarde ça se
passe on regarde les examens on lit la
littérature de ceux qui en avaient déjà
eu 5000 cas quand ça nous est arrivé
dessus d'accord et à partir de ça on
définit une stratégie pas avant en tout
cas bon c'est ce que nous on a pensé
c'est ce que l'on a fait voilà le terme
en effectivement quand on a vu cette
situation nous on a décidé qu'il fallait
puisque nous ne savions pas qui c'est
qui allait avoir des lésions et pas des
lésions comme ça avait été décrit en
chine avant que ça commence en france à
eh bien on a décidé on a dit il faut
tester les gens quand ils viennent
d'accord et on a commencé à tester les
gens quand ils venaient on a tout de
suite mis en place notre système de pcr
à très haut débit parce que vous savez
que les français ont été rapatriés du
yuan juste à côté de chez nous et donc
très rapidement on a commencé à tester
des centaines de des centaines de pcr et
donc on a on a fait ça voilà et donc au
fur et à mesure et bien on a augmenté 1
maintenant on a et on conseille aux gens
de mesurer leur saturation en oxygène
s'ils ont moins de 80 cas je pense qu'il
faut généraliser show qui viennent un
hôpital pour avant de l'oxygène parce
que sinon au moment où ils sentent
qu'ils sont un incident respiratoire
c'est juste avant de rentrer en réa et
même maintenant il ya même à marseille
il ya entre 50 et 60% des gens qui
rentrent en réanimation qui commencent
leurs soins en réanimation et cela on
aurait peut-être pu empêcher qu'ils
rentrent en réanimation les oxygen en
avant les anticoagulants avant voyez
donc c'est une notion qui est importante
qu'on pouvait pas connaître avant cette
discordance si vous voulez entre les
signes cliniques et l'état d'oxygénation
est d'ailleurs un de ceux qui est bon
pas mais plus jeunes
59 ans est mort dans boli pulmonaire
s'il était arrivé
trois semaines plus tard et c'est à mort
parce qu'on savait à ce moment là trois
semaines plus tard donc il ya cette
connaissance progressive si vous voulez
va mal avec des
les opinions très tranchées initial et
puis donc au fur et à mesure du savoir
nous avons modifié les choses comme je
voulais dire on a fait on a proposé tout
de suite hein
une proposition des essais
thérapeutiques limitées ce qui avait été
fait en chine avec des posologies avec
laquelle les familiers hydroxyque le
rookie et d'un essai thérapeutique qui a
toujours été avec un seul bras dont il a
été validé par le cpp à l'époque on a
rajouté parce que c'est ça fait partie
de la pratique clinique de l'asie trop
missiles dont on savait par ailleurs que
c'était un antiviral sur des virus à arn
et on a eu la surprise de voir que les
charges virales diminué à une vitesse
absolument spectaculaire donc on a dit
mais voilà un prévenu mais tout de suite
on a toujours tenu ode au courant le
ministère et on a voulu faire un essai
thérapeutique en disant écoutez c'est
azithromycine c'est tellement
impressionnant qu'on veut faire un
groupe hydroxy chloroquine un groupe
hydroxy chloroquine azithromycine et là
dans le cpp on est tombé sur un
méthodologistes qui voulait qu'on
reparte à zéro et qu'on fasse un groupe
de placebo ce que moi je pouvais pas
faire parce que je considérais que ce
n'est pas éthique
donc je vais pas faire et donc on a dit
on va faire ce que le soin courant et
l'état de la connaissance nous permet de
dire ce qu on ait publié donc c'est ce
qu'on a fait et donc en fuite et bien au
fur et à mesure on a continué à avoir
une politique de cette nature compte
tenu du fait que les gens ont soulevé
quelque chose qui m'étonne sur qui
m'étonne toujours des reins sur le sur
la toxicité potentielle de l'hydroxyde
brooklyn on a rajouté pour pour être sûr
qu'il y avait aucun problème on a
demandé au professeur de cardiologie de
vérifier tous nos tous nos
électrocardiogramme
on a fait systématiquement des cahiers
mis à tout le monde pour être sûr et on
a installé dans les hacher la dosage du
potassium en moins d'une demi-heure pour
être sûr de pouvoir tout de suite dans
le traitement donc tout ça au fur à
mesure que les questions sont levés on a
réagi pragmatiquement parce qu'on a
cette autonomie cette capacité à faire
les choses sur place et décider au fur
et à mesure de les faire fonctionner et
puis voilà maintenant
soit les gens comme ça et puis je vous
ai donné tous ces chiffres sont
entièrement officiel aussi les chiffres
que je vous donne je peux pas inventer
chiche je donne tout ça tous les jours à
la rs tous les morts tous les détecter
tous les positifs on peut pas inventer
des chiffres dans ce pays c'est c'est
l'assistance publique enfin c'est pas
peut pas inventer les chiffres c'est
donc il faut revenir sur terre gens qui
pensent qu'on invente les données mais
je ne sais pas il a fourni un pays
administrés parfois trop opportuniste
juku parce que il y aura beaucoup de
questions catherine et des roches avait
posé la question sur les cpp éthiques
oui moi je si vous voulez un avis j'ai
un avis qui est le mien est donc que je
veux bien partager vous vous savez je me
méfie peut-être parce que le temps a
passé je me méfie beaucoup de toutes les
modes
je suis pas très sensible non plus à ça
les modes méthodologique ce sont des
modes méthodologique c'est je vais vous
donner un exemple je voulais donner
parce que vous n'êtes pas obligés de me
croire mais je vous donne les documents
sur lequel ont péri ce document je lui
ai transmis c'est le cochrane library
sont spécialisés peut-être 25 ans pour
analyser toutes les publications et
toutes les recommandations d'accord et
comme maintenant les recommandations
depuis qu'il a été développé quelque
chose qui s'appelle la médecine basée
sur les évidences et de dire écoutez il
faut avoir un essai ou deux essais
randomisés donc là dessus et ils ont
étudié et eux c'est les rois de cette
analyse là et eux ils ont analysé 250
méta analyses et des analyses qui a
regroupé plusieurs années dans plus de
4000 analyse pour regarder s'il y avait
une différence de résultats et de
qualité entre les études randomisées les
études observationnelles et la
conclusion c'est qu'il n'ya pas de
différence
d'accord donc le fait que les études
randomisées soit l'alpha et l'oméga de
la prise en charge thérapeutique c'est
juste parfait canton recommandations
aussi parce qu'au bout d'un mois ces
choses qui pour moi aller de soi mais
s'il faut que j'explique jeu les
explique
moi j'ai regardé les recommandations de
société américaine de maladies
infectieuses je vous ai donné la
référence avec quelqu'un qui a fait une
fois cette analyse en disant combien des
recommandations société américaine de
maladies infectieuses sont basés sur au
moins une étude randomisée à 18% donc à
81 2% des recommandations thérapeutiques
en maladies infectieuses aux états unis
pour lequel il y à 0 étude randomisée
d'accord donc il faut être un peu plus
paisible avec sa avant de dire vous
savez c'est la règle et comme ça sinon
vous tuer c'est nous qui savons celle-ci
de l'idéologie c'est une des raisons sur
lesquelles je ne veux pas discuter de ça
ce plan idéologique je les fais déjà
j'avais fait jeudi li a chuté online où
j'avais invité costagliola pour parler
des méthodes nous n'étions pas d'accord
parce que sur le plan idéologique nous
ne sommes pas d'accord
maintenant nous ne sommes pas d'accord
non plus j'ai essayé de l'exprimer comme
médecin moi je ne veux pas faire ça sert
je ne peux pas à dire un malade
écoutez je vais vous donner un truc je
sais pas si un traitement ou pas dedans
et je vais vous tire au sort je sais pas
le faire
je n'ai jamais su le faire et je ne le
ferai pas et les malades qui accepte je
vous assure que 1 soit ils n'ont pas
compris soit la plupart refusent parce
qu'on n'est pas là pour ça d'accord et
donc il ya une vraie question qui est
est ce que on devient maniaque du
méthode si vous voulez qui manifestement
n'est pas réellement pratiqué très
fréquemment par des praticiens d'accord
ou est ce que on est dans le contrat
millénaire que nous avons deux je vais
faire du mieux que je peux avec ce que
je sais où ce que je crois savoir à ce
moment là pour vous spécifiquement et
donc il ya une vraie question et on a vu
pour revenir sur la question précisément
pour le cpp une dérive qui s'est faite
au début les cpp c'était fait pour ça
c'était fait pour attendez vous n'avez
pas faire l'expérience avec n'importe
quoi donc il faut qu'il y ait des sages
qui regardait donc mais prévu des
compositions de ces plages parce qu'on
appelle ses anciens jeux parce que moi
je les ai vus naître le le dedans il
était prévu qu'ils aient des gens de
sagesse dedans donc il fallait qu'ils un
prêtre un pasteur un rabbin des gens qui
la sagesse et le recul pour dire écoutez
faut faire attention est ce que c'est
nécessaire moi je peux vous dire j'ai
créé dans cette dans ce pays le premier
comité d'éthique animal en france
d'accord c'est vrai qu'on a eu des
problèmes terribles faculté de médecine
j'étais en charge de la recherche
je vous parle de 1989 et on a fait un
comité d'éthique pour dire écoutez
est-ce que ce truc est vraiment
nécessaire est ce que c'est d'avoir les
conditions de vie des allemands
est-ce que c'est pas totalement inutile
donc les cpp c'est à ça que ça sert les
cpp ça sert à dans notre comité
d'éthique animal et on avait interdit
les essais sur les chiens les chats et
les sages ce qui simplifiait les
rapports avec la population environnante
les rongeurs donc il y a une vraie
question c'est les cpp s'est pas fait
s'il ya une prise de pouvoir parler
méthodologistes c'est pas fait pour
valider la méthodologie c'est pour
savoir si ces mots rares c'est ça que ça
veut dire
est ce que on a le droit de faire ça
dans cette situation là et donc c'est
des lives la deux oui on a le droit de
faire ça dans cette situation là vous
avez le droit de faire de
l'expérimentation dans cette situation
là es tu devenu une dérive
administrativo méthodologique qui n'a
plus rien à voir avec la raison pour
laquelle ça a été créée donc c'est pour
ça que je pense qu'effectivement il faut
s'emparer
j'espère enfin moi je pense que le
législateur doit s'emparer de cette
question de cette réflexion sur
l'expérimentation humaine en sachant
écouter la l'histoire de nous faire
avoir un scpp pour d'autres pour faire
un écouvillon farrage et je pense que
c'est du délire voyez je pensais pas ça
mieux et je pense que deux en revanche
de faire des essais grande folie contre
les essais de non-infériorité et c'est
une en infériorité c'est de dire aux
gens je passe en qui on peut faire
accepter de dire à jean on va tester un
médicament pour savoir s'il est aussi
bon que le traitement de référence qui
c'est qui peut faire ça qu'ils aient
quelques est la personne qui va accepter
une chose pareille ça il ya dizaine
d'essais d'infériorité qui sont faits
tous les nouveaux médicaments ils sont
faits avec des essais de non-infériorité
parce qu'ils sont pas meilleurs que les
autres c'est pas vrai on n'arrive pas à
le démontrer donc si vous voulez il ya
une vraie réflexion de fond avoir moral
je pense qui est aussi un des éléments
probablement qui a fait jaillir une
telle une telle un tel conflit c'était
votre deuxième question
voilà je crois que
vous avez répondu aux questions
catherine oui si l'on sent bien le
parcours du patient qui arrive chez vous
est le même depuis depuis le hall est
améliorée quels sont les fois une
amélioration
si vous voulez où on a acheté du coup
quand on s'est rendu compte qu'on ne
voyait pas les saturations on a acheter
des appareils pour mesurer la saturation
à tous les gens qui se présentaient
d'accord et donc maintenant à partir de
95 ont fait les radios en fait c'est ça
ça a changé le l'anticoagulation
systématique ça a changé
voilà ce sont des choses qui ont changé
un an tout ça a changé au fur et à
mesure version merci sylvie bernier
merci monsieur le président le
professeur j'aurai deux questions la
première concerne la démocratie
depuis le début de ces auditions on a
beaucoup parlé de démocratie sanitaire
en quelque sorte qu auraient été oubliés
on a oublié de d'entendre les familles
non je trouve surtout oublier d'entendre
les patients mais je vais vous faire un
petit témoignage personnel qui est qui
rejoint celui de milliers de personnes
j'ai été malade vers le 15 mars à un
moment où il n'était pas possible d'être
testé puisque les tests s'étaient
réservés aux soignants et on nous
faisait 10 est donc de rester chez nous
avec des boîte de doliprane et à ce
moment là les malades de voeux n'étaient
en fait que des chiffres
on recevait tous les jours le nombre de
morts le nombre de malades et on n'était
guère plus que ça et je veux dire qu'au
moment où vous avez lancé votre votre
essai vous a été le premier à nous
donner l'espoir
je vous en sais gré je tiens à le dire
ici jusqu'à vos travaux le seul espoir
qu'on avait c'était une boîte de
doliprane voilà alors en matière de
démocratie sanitaire ça c'est une chose
mais pour le coup aujourd'hui on a le
sentiment qu'il n'ya pas de démocratie
dans le monde de la recherche
alors pourquoi est ce que c'est la force
de la pandémie qui explique ça
est ce que c'est la pression médiatique
ou est ce que c'est le fait comme vous
l'avez dit en préambule le fait qu'il
n'y a pas de patron qu'il n'est pas de
leader dans le monde des maladies
infectieuses
la deuxième question portera sur le
virus vous avez déclaré récemment il
existe deux hypothèses particulièrement
plausible soit que l'épidémie
disparaisse complètement
soit que l'épidémie reprennent et
deviennent saisonnière comment ça peut
être un cas où l'autre merci je suis je
jouerai si je suis très sensible à ce
que vous dites je vais vous dire la
raison pour laquelle en pratiquant en
réalité les broussailles et souvent
c'est des anecdotes ou des moments de
vie qui déclenche de tourner les choses
je pense que je les dis à 100 mais il se
trouve qu'une fois passant un dimanche
pour voir comment les choses se
passaient au moment où elles grandissent
et j'avais une de nos assistantes qui
est une fille merveilleuse qui avait
passé le week end à qui est épuisée et
elle était en train de se disputer avec
un papa qui avait un gosse de trois mois
dans les bras qui avait un masque sur
lui sur le gosse et elle voulait pas le
tester parce que ça faisait pas partie
des critères qu'on s'était donné donc ce
type dit ben écoutez moi je suis passé
par un aéroport amsterdam j'ai peur que
mon gosse au malade et je suis dit 'ça
suffit que vous faire découvrir en quoi
c'est en partir à tranquilliser
terrifiés ça ne changeait pas les choses
on peut pas c'est m ennuie il était
négatif
on a appris après car cet âge là c'était
la plupart du temps négatif mais on peut
pas laisser les gens sans leur proposer
ou leur donner une solution c'est mon
avis et je pense que d'être sur le
terrain
voyez c'est la raison pour laquelle je
crois tellement honorée d'être sur le
terrain ça nous a fait changer notre
manière de percevoir les choses parce
que on s'est rendu compte qu'il fallait
faire quelque chose non seulement
effectivement détecté d'abord pour les
rassurer pour leur dire s'il était ou
n'était pas positif
entre temps pour les prendre en charge
donc sur le sur la question de
l'évolution
je ne sais pas je ponds d'air toujours
ce que je dis en disant je vais je crois
pas au modèle je crois pas à la
prédiction tout ce par quoi moi j'arrive
à raisonner ces par analogie d'accord
donc je dis écouter ce
la plus proche passe comme ça peut-être
que ça va se passer comme ça c'est la
seule chose que je peux dire
donc vous savez qu'il ya six récits
coronavirus avant on a quatre qui sont
saisonniers ils ont bien dû commencer
par être autre chose que saisonniers
comme la grippe je voulais à la première
grille au moins du xxème siècle n'a pas
du tout été saisonnière durer toute
l'année a commencé l'été c'est la grippe
espagnole et puis c'est devenu quelque
chose qui est rythmée et qui est plutôt
par quand il ya un nouveau variant qui
est plutôt effectivement saisonniers
pour des raisons qu'on comprend que ce
non pas c'est pas le froid puisqu'il y
en a dans le sud en afrique
pendant des années les gens pensaient
qu'ils avaient pas de grip en afrique
parce qu'il pensait que vous c'est
influenza
ça veut dire de m woods a dit fred aux
influences du froid donc ça a été décrit
voulait à la renaissance comme étant une
maladie qui était sous l'influencé du
froid bien sûr c'était nous qui le
décrit vire en europe
et comme chez nous ces saisonniers au
moment où on arrive on pensait que c'est
une maladie liée au froid mais il y en a
autant dans les pays chauds même plus et
la zone importante il y en a toute
l'année et un peu plus pour l'afrique
que je connais un peu l'afrique de
l'ouest y en a plus pendant la saison
des pluies au contraire donc on connaît
on comprend pas bien ses rythmes
saisonniers mais chez nous c'est vrai
qu'il ya une saisonnalité
tous les virus respiratoires non pas les
mêmes saisonnalité je vous parlais de
par influence des trois c'est le
printemps et l'automne
c'est pas l'hiver donc si par analogie
fort c'est à dire écoutez comment à quoi
ça va ressembler analogiquement le sar
ce premier hop ça il ya une pique et
puis ça s'est arrêté en juillet donc il
ya plus de cas du tout et y en a plus
depuis
d'accord les autres coronavirus qui
s'est passé c'est que il ya un moment
probablement on n'a pas su quand parce
qu'on les a découvert un peu par hasard
les autres qu un virus pandémique et
bien il ya probablement une diffusion
qui s'est fait un peu partout dans le
monde parce que lui est partout partout
on trouve en afrique on trouve partout
en chine et donc il le il s'est installé
maintenant durablement avec nous et il a
une épidémie mais au jeu saisonnière
avec quelques cas sporadiques pendant le
reste de l'année et donc c'est les deux
modèles que je connais de coronavirus
tant que ses demandes étaient écoutés
aulas dans les modèles que je connaisse
et flat donc les chances que ça
ressemble au modèle qu'on connaît déjà
mais peut-être que ce sera quelque chose
de totalement différent
parce que c'est une autre maladie est
une nouvelle maladie et là en plus il
est en train de se passer des choses que
moi j'avais pas vu décrite en tout cas
avec les coronavirus et la vitesse de
mutation qu'il est actuellement
et donc je ne sais pas ce qu'il va
devenir vous n'avez pas répondu à ma
première question sur la démocratie dans
le monde la recherche qui à mon sens
écoutez je je je redoute que la
recherche auprès du tout démocratique
c'est ce que je pense que là la
recherche des clubs le sport de haut
niveau c'est pas démocratique l'idée que
c'est démocratique si vous voulez alors
dans les phases stationnaire c'est un
des grands grands épistémologique
historien des sciences dit vous savez il
ya trois phases dans un domaine de la
recherche dans un domaine particulier
il ya une première phase qui est une
phase pionnière est dans la phase
pionnière sont des gens qui sont
audacieux qui brise les lignes qui sont
poids zone et toute leur vie d'accord
c'est les pionniers et puis ensuite il
ya une phase de plateau si vous voulez
dans lequel qui est dite normale dans
lequel les choses avancent petit à petit
on rajoute un petit peu un petit peu un
petit peu c'est une phase dans lequel
qui devient collective c'est ce qu'on
appellerait la recherche démocratique
dans lequel et les études
multicentriques avec sept pays européens
chacun rajoute un petit bout ça c'est la
face du plateau et puis malheureusement
après il ya la face du déclin c'est à
dire que le chant s'épuiser puis un
autre chantier qui ne sais c'est comme
ça et c'est tout les épistémologie ce
temps observé ça s'appelait il ya des
phases
et quand vous êtes à une nouvelle phase
en particulier dans une phase de
découverte
le conflit sont terrifiants parce que et
c'est toute l'histoire comme ça si vous
lisez enfin moi je vous recommande de
lire mais j'ai changé d'avis un livre
merveilleux de la tour qui s'appelle
guerre et paix des microbes
la fille de pasteur c'est génial voilà
et c'est un vrai oeuvre scientifique
c'est pas un roman il y tous les
journaux de l'époque tous tous tous deux
qui rapporte ça pour voir comment
pasteur a réussi avec des en ayant des
forces qui était à la fois des forces
politiques des alliés qui étaient les
hygiénistes comment s'est passée l'idée
du germe
ça a été un combat terrible vous savez
que la marque qui est notre inventeur à
nous de l'évolution a été condamné à ne
plus parler par un team qui était un
immense scientifique qui était cuvier
qui était à l'époque tout puissant
science et qu'il a réellement rendu muet
alors que c'était plus grands
scientifiques de l'évolution du monde
c'est c'est la vie c'est un sport de
combat
je m'excuse mon prochain livre s'appelle
la science est un sport de combat oui
merci vous avez par les professeurs
avant de donner la parole s'il le veut
bien bernard jaume i ii de vitesse de
mutation
ce matin on nous a dit qu'il semblait
que le virus ne mute et pas je sais pas
qui à quoi bon jour je sais ce que j'ai
moi donc je pense qu'on fait plus de
séquences que n'importe qui ont fait
énormément de séquencer dans des
conditions d'ailleurs j'ai obligé de
faire venir les gens le week-end pour
pouvoir continuer à faire les séquences
donc on a fait à peu près 500 séquence
de virus depuis juillet parce qu on
était étonnés de voir la forme que
prenaient les cas cliniques et
l'épidémie depuis juillet elle
paraissait différents donc on avait et
dès le départ on a trouvé un mutant
qu'on a appelée marseille qui est à ccc
online vous pouvez les regarder qui est
assez qui présentait plus de buts à sion
que ce qu'on avait l'habitude de voir et
23 mutation par rapport aux à la souche
de human donc on pensait qu réellement
et celui là on a retracé sa source
c'est à dire on y est venu du maghreb
sur les bateaux et tous les premiers cas
ont été vraiment lié à ça et ensuite une
diffusion qui s'est passé dans
l'environnement on a eu 100 cas de ce
virus là actuellement ce virus-là à peu
près disparu depuis août et on pensait
que c'est lui qui avait plus le truc et
on a maintenant 7 mi temps
celui qui est le plus celui qui est le
plus actif actuellement c'est ce qu'on
appelait katroun à 60 cartes du 4 et
globalement si vous voulez si vous
regardez le nom mais vous voyez bien
qu'on peut pas parler de la même chose
moi je vous assure c'est des données je
viens de les écrire
regardez son online parce que mon mais
effectivement c'est une de the road
cette forme et ou online maintenant en
particulier la destituer sur un public
pour que tout le monde puisse en
profiter
si on regarde nous tous les virus que
nous avons eu jusqu'en mai ils comptent
regarde l'heure si vous regardez sur
notre site vous le verrez on a beaucoup
réfléchi pour leur présenter une manière
qui est visible sert sur un cercle
le degré de variation par rapport à la
souche initial si vous regardez la
différence entre les différentes souches
que nous avions par rapport à la souche
initial elle donnait un cercle de
diamètre x si vous regardez maintenant
ce que nous avons depuis juillet ce ce
diamètre a été multiplié par dix c'est à
dire la variabilité des virus que nous
avons maintenant les virus que nous
avons maintenant son antre présente
entre eux dix fois plus de variations
que les virus que nous avions jusqu'en
mai et c'est des variations qui sont
très intéressantes parce que ce sont des
variations convoi dans la dégradation
des génomes en général c'est à dire
c'est d'aider des variations c'est qu'à
quatre bases dans les génétique
qui sont intéressés l'adn et pour les
virus à arn place d'un thé vous avez eu
et donc la dégradation de ces verrues
est une normalement et réparer parce que
la plupart du temps elle est délétère et
donc là ce convoi majoritairement c'est
des mutations de tv rue qui traduisent
soit l'effet d'une enzyme qui est bien
connu chez les humains qui s'appelle la
peau beck qui a l'habitude de couper les
virus donc peut-être qu'au fur et à
mesure que ce virus s'est répandu il est
arrivé des formes qui qui qui permettent
la transformation de ces verrues soit il
est donc soit il se passe quelque chose
dans ce virus qui permet ça mais ce que
je peux vous dire alors ça on l'a aussi
étudié peut-être delfraissy n'a pas vu
encore mais moi je les ai vus parce
qu'on a envoyé le papier on a comparé
100 cas à partir de juillet et samples
cas avant pour regarder quel était le
degré de leurs troubles de coagulation
et donc ils ont beaucoup moins de
troubles de coagulation ils sont moins
sévères et la mortalité est plus faible
donc il se passe quelque chose avec ce
lyrisme qui en fait quelque chose de
différent voilà et donc moi je regrette
voyez que on vous dit ça mais moi j'ai
téléphoné au conseiller du ministre pour
lui dire et pour lui donnez donnez donc
la question que vous me posiez à toutes
les semaines je téléphone en tête eisner
qui est le conseiller du ministre pour
lui dire écoute je vais parler de ça
voilà ce que nous avons si vous voulez
les données vous les avez donc je je je
reste à l'intérieur d'une démocratie où
je partage mes résultats mais je les
partage ensuite avec la planète entière
sans cap
permettez moi d'insister parce que la
ferme semble d'importance sans qu'à
comparer train avant et après -2 mais
c'est suffisant pour je sais pas ce que
vous appelez une vision globale moi non
plus moi non plus avec global board mais
est ce suffisant pour affirmer williams
mutation ah non mais là vous savez que
constater la mutation c'est rien à voir
sur la mutation c'est un truc qu'on
constate dans le virus donc nous on a
fait 500 5 ans de génomes viraux
d'accord donc la pelouse de juillet août
c'est visible on voit à la place d'avoir
cette base cette balle
on s'est rendu compte nouer d'autres que
l'on pouvait séquence est directement
les virus avec les nouvelles on peut
peut séquencer les virus maintenant
directement en dehors de sans avoir
besoin de cultiver
quand est ce que tu es beaucoup et
pratiquement chez tous ceux qui ont
moins de 20 ct on peut avoir le virus
entier dans huit heures qui suivent le
génome entier de 8 heures qui suivent
donc je voulais de pratiquer des génomes
quand on a tous encore une fois c'est à
dire on a le prélèvement on voit que les
cités sont bas on peut les envoyer
on peut les envoyer en séquences et puis
on a nous un mécanisme d' analyse des
séquences qui nous permet de voir ça
voilà bien le papier sur notre site
seulement nous regardons tout cela bien
sûr avec beaucoup d'intérêt dernière
jonnier merci monsieur le président je
voudrais monsieur prix l'an revenir sur
votre propos liminaires et parce que le
professeur à outils a répondu et je
voudrais lui expliquer quel était
l'intérêt de notre démarche qui était de
vouloir vous auditionnés en présence et
on débat avec d'autres spécialistes
d'autres personnalités ayant une
compétence éminentes comme la vôtre
c'est une méthode que nous utilisons
couramment dans cette commission enquête
pourquoi parce que et la discussion qui
vient d'avoir lieu le démontre
parfaitement vous pouvez avec un savoir
technique qui est incomparable aux
nôtres en la matière nous faire un
exposé pendant 10 minutes de virologie
pour nous expliquer que le virus semble
muté mais un autre virologue et milan le
professeur lina nous a expliqué et nous
a dit plusieurs fois que non le virus
n'avait pas muté et ça ça ne fait pas
beaucoup avancer notre compréhension
nous nous nous avons besoin nous ne
sommes pas dans des conflits
ce n'est pas notre méthode ici de mettre
en scène des matchs de catch et de
générer du conflit
c'est notre méthode de faire ressortir
les points qui font clivages et si pour
vous ça peut être pénible par
ce que vous avez des conflits avec
d'autres collègues d'autres confrères
qui sont parfois effectivement virulent
nous ce n'est pas ce que nous ce n'est
pas notre ja lire ce n'est pas notre
problème j'en suis tout à fait désolé
pour les uns et les autres mais nous
nous devons rendre compte aux français
aux personnes qui résident sur notre
territoire de ce qui s'est passé et sur
ces sujets fondamentaux qui sont les
vôtres la recherche les tests le
dépistage
vous faites partie des personnes qui
avaient une expertise et qui ont été en
désaccord avec d'autres et pouvoir vous
entendre vous répondre entre vous et
pour nous essentiel dans la construction
de notre représentation de notre
compréhension de ce qui se passe ce qui
s'est passé de ce qui se passe voilà
donc je vais pas poursuivre là dessus
mais comprenez juste que nous ne
souhaitions pas vous faire vivre un
moment pénible pour vous à titre
personnel je comprends que ce n'est pas
agréable d'être poursuivi devant des
instances disciplinaires d'avoir des
procédures en justice mais nous nous
avons la nécessité de mener notre
travail dans les meilleures conditions
et très tranquillement professeurs avec
le respect que je vous dois vous ne nous
aidez pas là dans notre tâche votre
exposé est certes très intéressant mais
il ne nous ils ne mettent pas à
progresser de façon suffisante alors je
veux en venir à quelques à quelques
quelques questions non vous allez
répondre at-elle une enquête parue vous
avez région venir à quelques
questionnements parce que vous avez là
la tension je dirais de nous envoyer en
préliminaire à cette audition un
document extrêmement complet de réponse
à notre question ce matin nous
débattions et nous l'avions fait au
rapporteur par le rapporteur
mais vous ne vous inquiétez pas chers
collègues vous avez tout comprendre ce
matin nous avons eu une discussion et
les jours lors d'auditions présente sur
la question des tests et de la lenteur
je ne refait pas l'histoire du
déploiement des thèses dans notre pays
et au printemps quand nous étions en
pleine vague épidémique
nous voyons tous devant votre institut
des fils de personnes qui venaient pour
faire des têtes et vous pratiquiez
beaucoup de tests et dont le
document vous nous avez envoyé vous
dites j'ai fait deux cent mille nous
avons fait il ya je suis deux cent mille
tests sur cent mille personnes alors est
ce que vous pourriez nous préciser ce
calendrier est comme manifestement vous
avez commencé à faire des tests en
nombre très rapidement comment avez vous
fait comment vous êtes vous procurer le
matériel nécessaire les réactifs et
c'est alors que ailleurs en france
bah on n'arrivait pas à faire de tel
donc manifestement vous avez réussi là
où là où on échoué plus tôt donc
j'aimerais que vous me préciser comment
vous avez procédé
la deuxième question c'est nous avait
dit quelque chose de très fort mais nous
vous nous avez dit il ya une destruction
physique de l'organisation des maladies
infectieuses
si j'ai bien compris à paris enfin en
ile-de-france mais j'aimerais que vous
précisiez qu'est ce que c'est que cette
destruction parce que il me semble mais
peut-être le démentir et vous alors j'ai
vu aussi qu'il ya des polémiques là
dessus mais il me semble que globalement
les patients qui ont été hospitalisés en
maladies infectieuses en ile de france
n'ont pas eu de perte de chance par
rapport à ceux qui ont été hospitalisés
en maladies infectieuses dans d'autres
régions donc qu'est-ce que cette
destruction physique dont vous avez
parlé j'ai compris que le fait d'avoir
scindé géographiquement mais j'imagine
des services des capacités mais
j'imagine que ça allait au delà puisque
la critique est très dur et puis enfin
dernier point que je ne souhaitais pas
soulevé parce que c'est pas l'obliger
exactement ici mais vous êtes vous êtes
revenu sur hydroxy chloroquine et
l'azithromycine et vous avez dans votre
exposé préliminaire expliqué un principe
qui me paraît très très sens celui du
benchmark vous vous regardez ce qu'il
fallait et rangez vous avez cité la
chine et l'important savoir qu'elle a
qui là qu'elle a accumulées aujourd'hui
il semblerait que la plupart des pays de
des états unis au japon la corée du sud
à l'allemagne en passant par la chine ne
recommande pas ce traitement là donc il
semblerait que la science a parlé et
c'est la liste des pays qui ont qu'ils
ne recommandent pas ou qui même
déconseillent l'utilisation
l'hydro xi chloroquine est extrêmement
longue j'en ai j'ai cité juste quelques
pays et ça ce n'est pas un jugement sûr
c'est tout à fait sain de d'entrée quand
nouveaux problèmes arrivent dans la
recherche de médicaments de traitement
possible et deham tenter de trouver que
ça pourrait être efficace mais
aujourd'hui comprenez que nous qui
sommes on va dire des spectateurs
engagés de cette question et la prise en
charge
on constate que dans le monde entier ce
traitement n'est plus utilisé
donc est ce que ça signifie que le monde
entier est aujourd'hui dans l'erreur oui
merci vous inquiétez pas vous allez
pouvoir répondre merci bernard de ces
questions donc je voulais de la parole
professeurs pour la réponse serait donc
je pense je ne suis pas d'accord du tout
et vous bien sûr sur aucun des points le
premier point le premier point c'est que
la question ait pas été ce n'est pas un
débat entre si vous avez des
affirmations auxquelles je suis en total
désaccord et à 4,6 milliards de gens qui
vivent dans d'autres pays dans lequel on
vit de livres cycloclean donc vous
pouvez pas liquidé ça comme ça je passe
mon temps à faire des méta-analyses rien
que cette semaine il est sorti ce qui
est de sortie en arabie saoudite et en
iran
il en sort à peu près dans tous les pays
du monde donc on ne peut pas dire ça
vous pouvez pas me dire à moi vous savez
mieux que moi ce que c'est que les méta
analyse sur l'hydroxyde qui ne vous avez
une opinion et vous voyez bien qu'il
n'est pas possible de ce répit on sait
le temps qu'il fait les opinions vous
savez encore une fois si vous aviez
demandé au départ à quoi sert la 14ème
mois je disais à partir de février à 14h
c'est un fantasme analogique avec la
quarantaine ça n'a pas de sens sur le
plan clinique c'est pas vrai d'accord il
ya d'ailleurs une une étude de méta
analyse qui fait partie du rapport que
je vous ai envoyés et que bien entendu
il peut être distribué à tout le monde
la deuxième chose c'est que le temps
encore une fois fait le tri au début les
gens disaient ça ne sert à rien de faire
des tests pourquoi ils n'ont pas fait
des tests par c'est parce que les
centres nationaux de référence leur ont
dit écoutez c'est compliqué difficile de
faire les tests et une fois que cet
embranchement était parti il est
extrêmement difficile de revenir sur
cette branche
extrêmement difficile et donc c'est pas
vrai qu'ils n'avaient pas les réactifs
je les dis je le redis puis je vous le
redis encore une fois si vous voulez les
laboratoires vétérinaires ont écrit à
peu près à tout le monde y compris au
conseil scientifique pour leur dire
qu'ils avaient de faire quoi 300 mille
tests et les autres l'auront pas répondu
et nous on a répondu et on sent des
services d'accor donc vous ne pouvez pas
penser que dans une crise comme ça où il
ya des opinions différentes
vous avez les par la magie du sénat
faire que les gens votent d'accord la
fin c'est le temps qui trient le temps
tri et à la fin on voit ce qui s'est
passé d'accord c'est à la fin qu'on voit
ce qui s'est passé quand encore une fois
à la ligue roc cyclo keane et donc pour
les tests on a fait ce qu'on fait quand
on est en situation de crise c'est à
dire tous les jours on s'est débrouillé
nous mêmes on a fabriqué de quoi faire
430 mille tests nous mêmes chez nous
l'eau phillies est d'accord on s'est
organisé pour faire face ces
l'intendance qui a suivi la décision
c'est pas la tendance qui a commandé la
décision c'est comme ça qu'on a vu les
choses et c'est comme ça que je
continuerai à les voir quant à votre
opinion sur qui et qui ne donne pas elle
aussi chloroquine je vous assure je
viens d'avoir un papier accepté sur
lequel on a mis l'ensemble des pays qui
recommandait roxy chloroquine la
mortalité dans l'ensemble des pays qui a
gardé avec lockheed et ça n'est pas ce
que vous dites donc je ne suis pas
d'accord
donc vous imitez vous émettez une
opinion scientifique et donc vous voyez
je suis pas de corps et donc que chacun
fasse son métier et les vaches regardent
et vous entendrez deux éco et le temps
triera à la fin on verra bien
ainsi vous nous bien sûr tu as c'est
donc c'est je ne sais pas encore dans le
document je crois assez dense et dans le
document
c'est dans le document que nous
communiquons bien sûr l'ensemble de nos
conseillers parce que la lecture est
intéressant de nos commissaires pardon
monsieur le président je ne suis pas
dans un débat d'opinion je suis
rapporteur d'une je suis rapporteur
d'une commission denquête et professeurs
je vais vous citer une liste incomplète
d'ailleurs des pays qui actuellement
dans les autorités de santé déconseille
les usages de l'hydroxyde chloroquine
si ce que disent ces autorités est
inexact je veux bien l'entendre je viens
d'entendre votre opinion qui ne la
partage pas mais vous ne pouvez pas dire
que c'est une opinion de ma part aux usa
la haine ni h et ligne fictions diseases
society of america déconseillent
l'utilisation l'aude roxy chloroquine en
grande bretagne c'est déconseillé dans
le monde l'organisation mondiale de la
santé de demande de ne pas l'utiliser
quelle que soit la gravité l'italie des
conseils la belgique déconseille
l'allemagne déconseille le brésil le
portugal la chine le chinese center for
disease control and prevention estime
que l'utilisation doit être déconseillé
quelle que soit la gravité le japon
l'australie l'espagne le canada
l'european medicines agency pour
l'europe la suisse et la corée du sud
je n'aimais pas une opinion si ces
recommandations sont erronées je peux
l'entendre et jeu j'attends qu'on nous
l'expliquent mais je ne vais pas mené de
débats scientifiques avec vous ce n'est
pas le sujet je réfute simplement
professeur le fait que vous transformiez
ma question en un débat d'opinion entre
vous et moi je respecte votre opinion et
je vous aimez les recommandations des
pays concernés encore une fois je vous
recommande de vous verrez encore une
fois on a un papier dans lequel on
explique ça est extrêmement précisément
sondés général vous savez pour pour
faire des généralités trouvé qu'on est
d'accord c'est extrêmement simple moi je
peux vous dire aux états unis et
agissent un pays fédéral il ya un tiers
des états dans lequel hydroxy floraux
qu'il est recommandé
il ya un tiers des états dans lequel
certains trop ce qu'il faut faire et un
tiers des états qui suivent les
recommandations de fossiles c'est un
pays fédéral
donc il n'ya pas d'homogénéité aux états
unis et compare même aux états unis à
des conflits les conflits autour de
l'hydroxyde de routine sont mondiaux et
avec qui compare même aux états unis
état par état
quelle est la mortalité et au co vide
par rapport à la prescription ou non
d'hydroxyde de rocky
pardon la liste oui oui vous les
regarderai la liste nous on a fait une
liste on a marqué chaque source
à chaque de chaque source d'où elle
vient comment elle fait comment on fait
de la séance donc vous vous le lirez
vous avez si vous souhaitez que je vous
enlevez le vol près print je vous
enverrai n'y a pas de problème mais moi
je le fais je trouve que c'est un sujet
sur lequel vous imaginez bien qu'on
travaille nous on a estimé qu'il y avait
4 6 4 1 6 milliard de gens qui vivaient
dans les pays auxquels ont recommandé ou
entre où on dit vous pouvez tirer la
ligue roc cyclo routine se voulait donc
encore une fois donc ça veut dire que
ces débats qui sont des débats
scientifiques très bien nous on l'a
écrit il ya une liste une liste des
sources comme on a l'habitude de faire
et puis et puis voilà vous regarderez si
vous arrivez à les analyser
où vous les ferez analysés par quelqu'un
qui vous aidera à les analyser mais on
ne peut pas de manière péremptoire dire
écoutez tous ces pays là ne le font pas
et ne l'ont pas fait se passe parce que
c'est pas mal ça n'est pas les données
que mercy il y avait la question sur les
tests donc vous dites vous êtes s'est
constitué vous même vous avez fait
moi-même vos tests pour arriver à cenon
et puis vous les avez eu au niveau des
laboratoires vétérinaires et ça ça n'a
pas été ça n'a pas été très rapidement
pris en compte sur le plan national quoi
un retard par rapport à écouter mozart
ou non j'ai eu l'occasion de dire au
président qui m'a confirmé quand j'ai
revu que la pcr est une chose
extrêmement simple qui posait pas
beaucoup de problèmes et que tout le
monde était capable de faire comme on
voit maintenant et à l'époque il a été
surpris et quand il est revenu il m'a
dit écoutez c'est vrai vous avez été
premier à me dire ça on me disait que
c'était un truc très compliquée qui
pourrait être fait que de récentes de
référence donc il est parti 1 c'est ce
qu'on nous a régulièrement
donc si vous voulez là encore je ne
crois pas que quand on soit dans une
situation comme ça parce que je me suis
déjà trouvé
si vous voulez on puisse avoir un débat
entre les gens qui s'est quand même la
chose la plus simple du monde lorsque
nous on en faisait déjà derrière 150000
de pc que l'adn c'est l'adn
si vous voulez et puis les gens qui
disent non c'est très compliqué et c'est
très complexe et le temps qu'ils trient
et c'est pas ici et maintenant qu'on va
trier tous les éléments qui sont liées à
cette donnée pour l'autre question que
vous posez non il faut regarder les
morts vous les regarderai les morts moi
je les connais les morts je sais qui est
mort dans quelle ville dans quelles
régions et communes mans et combien une
jeune qui sont je le sais bien
donc je connais les résultats là aussi
il faut aller regarder les résultats et
regarder les otages et publié d'ailleurs
les résultats et c'est ceux de santé
publique france c'est pas les miens il
faut regarder bien il ya une morale il
ya une surmortalité ici et dans l'est
qui est tout à fait spécifique
il ya quelque chose de particulier avec
une vraie surmortalité et y compris dans
des tranches d'âge on n'a pas l'habitude
de voir une surmortalité donc si vous
voulez d'ailleurs si en pratique de ne
pas traiter pas des moustiques et les
gens c'était la même chose que quand on
les traite et diagnostics ont souhaité
plus dans merci les questions des
rapporteurs étant terminée j'invite
maintenant nous commissaire a posé les
questions j'ai déjà 3 3 6 6 3 9 11
inscriptions donc je vais les prendre
quelques-uns par quelques-uns et vous
répondrais de façon collective en notant
après de façon groupée
merci davance martin livriez merci
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
professeur rappelle je vous rappelle
simplement que nous excuse moi tu avoir
coupé martin que nous devons finir nos
travaux pour 17 heures 17 heures il est
16 heures 13 très bien que quelques
questions j'espère rapide
la première que je reprends le début de
cette pandémie on est dans une pandémie
arrive assez rapidement une controverse
scientifique qui qui prend toute la
place au niveau communication et presse
et de cette controverse on arrive même à
un combat scientifique
je ne suis ni médecin ni spécialiste et
je suis avalé par ce combat par cette
inquiétude qui naît entre nous tous
parce qu'on ne comprend pas tout et ça
fait quatre points que ce combat dur
perdure et continue et je me dis
qu'aujourd'hui il ya peut-être une
possibilité de s'en sortir mais là c'est
vous qui pouvez vraiment mai
vous avez déjà donné un élément de
réponse tollé en disant idéologiquement
je ne peux pas et pourtant je me pose la
question
ce combat qui ne méritent pas je trouve
d'être pourrait s'arrêter si vous
décidiez vous parce que vous en avez la
capacité les moyens et aujourd'hui
malheureusement visiblement le les
patients puisqu'il a de plus en plus de
patients et de malades dans votre
département de faire justement ces
essais en double aveugle parce que
finalement on se dit je comprends votre
principe de dire pas de placebo pour les
parce que parce qu'il ya des gens qui
n'ont pas être soigné mais aujourd'hui
si vous avez raison si vous aviez raison
depuis le début combien de patients
n'ont pas été soignées parce que
finalement on a préféré l'idéologie à
une tentative dont je vous pose vraiment
cette question parce qu'elle me paraît
tellement importante aujourd'hui de se
dire si vous avez raison professeurs
c'est tellement important aujourd'hui si
vous avez raison à ce que l'idéologie
est supérieur à le fait d'avoir raison
donc voilà ma première question
la deuxième concerne indirectement cela
aussi c'est la communication est ce
qu'aujourd'hui la communication n'a pas
pris le pas sur le vrai travail
scientifique et sur ce besoin de
controverses qui est indispensable je
pense dans le monde scientifique mais
comme partout ailleurs et qu'aujourd'hui
on est plus dans la controverse menant
le combat et comment on sort de ce débat
pour avancer pour permettre au monde
entier de s'en sortir parce que c'est un
sujet mondial c'est parce que j'ai
franco français et bah écoutez ce sera
tout pour le moment parce que j'avais
une autre question mais je les ai perdus
merci président bonjour au dessert je
suis sénateur des français établis hors
de france ou bénéficier d'une grande
renommée
une reconnaissance parmi les trois
millions et demi de français qui vivent
à l'étranger
je voulais vous poser une question cette
pandémie a débuté en asie à toucher à
peu près simultanément l'europe et
l'amérique du nord puis
l'amérique latine au mois d'avril du
quai d'orsay en passant par de nombreux
experts des projections catastrophique
était annoncé sur l'afrique
certains pays on avait même le nombre de
respirateurs je pense entre autres à
l'ethiopie par habib par une centaine ou
par million d'habitants on avait le mali
on avait l'egypte et un certain nombre
de pays qui finalement n'ont pas connu
ces vagues aussi importante que dans
d'autres territoires
vous-même français d'étrangers vous vous
connaissez très bien l'afrique et le
sénégal en particulier et j'aimerais
savoir pourquoi et comment vous
expliquez que cette catastrophe annoncée
n'a pas eu lieu et quel est votre
diagnostic et enfin une dernière
question très rapide avec plus de dix
mille cas en 24 heures ces derniers
temps on peut comprendre l'anxiété de la
société face à cette pandémie
si vous aviez trois recommandations à
faire
quelle serait-elle trois recommandations
quelle serait-elle et comment voyez vous
l'évolution de cette pandémie dans les
deux mois qui viennent puisque c'est là
qu'on nous annonce aussi selon les
sources des avis très divergents
merci merci roger karoutchi
le professeur moi je partage la dernière
question d'ailleurs de mon ami régnard
c'est vrai qu'on aimerait tous avoir un
peu votre opinion sur ce qui va se
passer ou ce qui pourrait se passer dans
les semaines qui viennent moi je
voudrais poser deux questions assez
clair 1
qu'est ce que vous pensez du fait que
les médecins libéraux que les médecins
tout court pour beaucoup ont été bien
souvent contraints de ne pas appliquer
votre traitement et de ne pas pouvoir le
prescrire un moment où dans le même
temps les mêmes autorités scientifiques
affirmait qu'il n'y avait pas de
traitement qu'il n'y avait pas de
médicaments et que dans ses conséquences
dans ces conditions les gens comme
disait ma collègue sylvie vermeillet
soit on leur disait vous prendrez le
doliprane
soit ils pouvaient avoir votre
traitement et si ça n'était pas ça il
n'y avait en tout cas au début rien est
ce que c'est normal dans en 2020 dans un
pays comme le nôtre de dire à des gens à
qui on dit vous êtes positif
vous restez chez vous priez et prenez du
doliprane
est ce que c'est normal ma deuxième
question chacun dit ce qu'il veut
ma deuxième question elle et elle est
simple ce matin je disais au professeur
delfraissy
j'ai beaucoup d'estimé pour le
conseiller scientifique pour chacun de
ses membres c'est pas le sujet mais la
réalité elle est quand même que
l'autorité du conseil scientifique ne
semble pas toujours être suivie par le
gouvernement
ce qui veut dire que on a
institutionnalisé un débat sur mon
passionnant entre scientifiques médecins
dans les médias et ailleurs mais qui en
réalité est extrêmement anxiogènes pour
la population
est ce que dans ces conditions là vous
pensez que le conseil scientifique tel
que défini avec les missions qui sont
les siennes a encore du sens aujourd'hui
olivier henno
oui merci professeur pour vos propos -
j'ai une question qui est en
prolongement avec le débat de ce matin
ce matin on nous a dit le système de
santé français n'était pas prêt alors on
a eu quelques explications un peu
complexe un peu flou
parmi lesquels oui mais un autre système
de santé il est trop curatif
alors ma question elle concerne votre
que diagnostic par rapport à notre
système de santé
pourquoi nous n'étions pas prêts moi je
pense que ça n'est pas seulement une
question de moyens puisque notre pays
consacre un certain nombre de moyens
à son système de santé je pense que
c'est plus une question d'organisation
et d'ailleurs on nous a dit aussi que
parmi les pays qui étaient mieux
préparés il y avait l'allemagne et puis
je m'interroge aussi sur le fait que
notre système
comme beaucoup de choses en france
d'ailleurs et souvent un peu trop
corporatistes et donc je voulais votre
diagnostic sur sur toutes ces questions
je vous remercie
sapin oui oui professeur président merci
de deux questions très rapide parce que
vous y avez répondu en partie déjà
néanmoins je voudrais quelques
précisions sur la première elle concerne
la relation à la chine
ce matin le professeur delfraissy au nom
du conseil scientifique nous disait que
les informations qu'il avait lui-même en
échange direct avec les chinois sous
l'oeil bienveillant de l' oms nous
faisait comprendre dans ses propos qu'il
n'avait qu'une confiance très très
réservé sur ce que les chinois nous
apporter aussi bien en termes
scientifiques que clinique et qu'il
doutait fort de beaucoup de leurs propos
quant à vous effectivement vous êtes
appuyé au départ quand vous avez lancé
le processus chloroquine en disant voilà
c'est peut-être la solution est
aujourd'hui un regard assez pertinent ni
même assez globale pour juger de
l'efficacité ou non mais en tout cas
vous êtes appuyé sur les expertises
chinoise pour dire voilà en chine il ya
quelque chose qui marche et bien testons
le en france donc je voudrais savoir
quelle est en fait cette relation et
cette différence entre les apports du
conseil scientifique et puis ce que vous
vous avez décrété puis deuxièmement je
voudrais qu'on revienne sur la mutation
la mutation et les souches vous nous
dites
effectivement il ya de plus en plus de
souche en tout cas c'est ce que vous
constatez c'est ce que j'ai cru
comprendre dans votre exposé mais ce qui
fait les choux les souches
c'est les mutations du virus les
différentes souches de virus qu'on
rencontre elles proviennent de la
mutation du virus
qu'elles soient ou non plus pathogène
plus virulente mais en tout cas elles
viennent de là donc ce qu'on voudrait
savoir simplement parce que tous les
gens qui nous écoutent c'est ce qu'il
entendent à la radio ou à la télé le
virus mute il oui ou non parce que ce
matin on nous a dit non
oui merci beaucoup monsieur le président
monsieur le professeur
j'ai une poignée questions concernant
les essais thérapeutiques à vous avez
des protocoles
alors est-ce que des hameaux de
connaissances vous avez évoqué la
bibliographie que vous avez faite
concernant les chinois mais est ce que
dans ce que vous préconisiez il ya eu
des études comparatives qui sera fait en
fonction de vos préconisations parce
qu'on ya des personnes qui ont dit que
c'était pas forcément pertinent donc
est-ce que vous avez connaissance de
l'équipe qui aurait utilisé conformément
à vos recommandations au protocole la
deuxième chose la liberté de la liberté
de prescrire a été mise en cause dans
notre pays
alors pensez vous qu'il ya eu des pertes
de change liées à cette liberté à cette
obstruction
la dernière chose revient alors cela
concerne également les mutations
alors je voudrais savoir vous avez dit
qu'il y avait vous avez commandé des
génomes que vous avez fait des cinq ans
âge il ya eu elle vous avez eue et cette
mutation
alors sur quoi portait ces mutations et
des mutations ou des permutations
d'acides aminés quel niveau il y avait
ces mutations pour que ce sera un peu
plus clair pour tout le monde
je vous remercie mr si vous allez
répondre à cette première salve la
deuxième suivra pour les premières
questions
si vous voulez je suis content que vous
me posez cette question mais je me
demande pourquoi vous la posez pas au
ministère la santé parce que c'était pas
compliqué de dire ce qu'il ya des gens
qui adorent faire des essais pourquoi
ils ont pas fait un essai identique lors
qu'ils n'aillent trop vicitmes contre
placebo comme en bas donc globalement
globalement ce que vous voulez et c'est
une des reproches majeurs que j'ai fait
pour ce rapport ce ce conseil
scientifique c'est que tous les essais
avaient été décidés à vanter la moindre
réunion du conseil scientifique
il était question que du raid ainsi viré
du
le lopinavir jamais l'hydroxyde
lentilles qui était le seul pour lequel
on avait des données préliminaires et
qu' il n'y a jamais eu d'organisation
c'est le comité scientifique n'a pas été
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles je
me suis mis en retrait de ce conseil
scientifique
ce conseil scientifique n'a jamais
piloté quoi que ce soit par recherche
locaux vides rien et donc qui sait qui a
apporté les données pour savoir que les
enfants n'étaient pas affectés c'est
nous toutes les données vous avez là ça
me fait ça m'amuse beaucoup que les gens
parlent de maintenant qui découvre que
les ct n'ont pas tous la même valeur
ça fait deux mois et demi qu'on l'a
écrit non quand même donc le débat il
est cette semaine
alors donc ça c'est des choses que le
pilotage de l'état aurait dû faire
aurait dû dire écoutez dites nous
quelles sont les limites du s'étaient
dites nous quelle est l'incidence des
différentes couches de populations dites
nous quelle est l'incidence chez les
patients symptomatiques et
asymptomatiques
ça c'est du pilotage d'accord et ce
pilotage
c'est le conseil scientifique et des
faire et je peux vous le dire j'ai écrit
très tôt en disant écoutez ce conseil
scientifique ne peut pas piloter une
recherche de crise
j'ai fait les propositions dont je me
suis au thé parce que je je je pensais
que je continue à penser que plus utile
à faire ça sur place parce quelle
décision prendre tous les jours et que
je me sens à tort ou à raison capable de
le faire mais j'ai proposé des gens qui
faisait des centaines de milliers de pc
r je veux dire j'ai proposé aux portes
de toulouse et celui de créteil
j'ai proposé des gens qui connaissaient
parfaitement la pharmacopée la
pharmacologie j'aurais jamais validé
l'idée de cycle est un poison mortel
donc il y avait des gens qui étaient
capables de mener une véritable
politique scientifique ce conseil
scientifique n'était pas fait de gens
qui étaient capables de mener une
politique scientifique donc je le dis
j'ai exprimé aux prisons de la
république et au premier ministre peut
pas faire plus voilà donc je regrette
effectivement il fallait faire une
politique très bien en disant écoutez
puisque c'est comme ça
vérifier ce que dira roule-t-il à
quelques éléments près commence à les
traiter comme ça fait le pur pour
répondre à votre question sur
l'efficacité
oui avant que ce soit interdit dans les
ehpad nous avons commencé à faire une
étude qui est là aussi
online que vous pouvez regarder
les ehpad sur lequel nous avons une
baisse de 50 % de la mortalité dans les
étapes dans lequel on a pu traiter les
gens par rapport aux enfants on n'a pas
pu les traiter c'est vrai on est passé
de 27 à 14 %
c'est nos données aussi il faut le
regarder à l'appui il faut faire pareil
plutôt que dire elle n'est pas d'en
faire donc je je pense
il ya encore le temps et encore les
malades je pense que les gens qui se
posent la question moi je me pose pas la
question c'est pas à moi qu'il faut la
poser la question et non seulement je me
la pose pas mais là non plus il faut pas
vivre dans des mythes truc il ya un
énorme papier qui est sorti aux états
unis american journal of medicine qui
expliquent où est la place de
l'hydroxyde clos routine d'après eux en
particulier au départ du fait de son
rôle contre les facteurs qui entraînent
la coagulation la coagulation est en
partie due à la sécrétion d'auto
anticorps ces anticorps
antiphospholipides qui sont les mêmes
anticorps qu'on trouve dans le lupus et
c'est la raison pourquoi on donne et
roxy claudine dans le bus
donc tout ça sont des éléments là aussi
c'est intéressant de parler de science
donc ça c'est des éléments dont on à la
réalité maintenant vous parler de
communication en la communication
personnellement je pense j'ai toujours
pensé que la manière dont vous voyez les
choses on partait dans le mur c'est ce
que je pense donc moi je n'ai fait que
je n'ai jamais porté d'opinion à part
quand vous me le demandez dans une
situation officielle sur la politique du
gouvernement je n'ai porté
je n'ai fait que donner des chiffres et
les données que nous avions et que nous
étions les seuls à avoir dans ce pays et
parfois les seuls à vendre
d'accord je les fais que ça donc et vous
les avez je suis désolé je pensais qu on
transmettra à tout le monde vous allez
jo sans limite
quatre pages de résultats de ce que nous
faisons et qui officiait comme peut pas
tricher avec sa enfin ses défauts lignac
lé regard des accords donc encore une
fois équipe usée
c'est vrai que cette même communication
que j'ai fait peut-être que vous trouvez
que les nuisibles
il ya une quantité de pays qu'ils ont
utilisé cette communication pour prendre
des mesures et pour prendre des mesures
qui ont été fonctionnelle moi j'ai des
amis en algérie je vous assure qu'ils
testaient plus que ce contest en france
à ce moment là d'accord parce qu'il
avait compris qu'il fallait veste est
d'accord donc il y avait une faut pas me
sortir l'angleterre il est sorti des
papiers aux états unis
et en angleterre sur les meilleurs
journaux du monde où les gens affirmé
qu'ils avaient que un traitement marcher
ou pas marcher il sans même avoir fait
un test biologique
donc il ya un phénomène de déroute qui
n'est pas que français il ya un vrai
phénomène de dents qui est écoutée ou
est-ce qu'on va où est ce qu'on va
et pour revenir je m'excuse pour les
chinois étaient posées pour une autre
question pourquoi moi je pense que ça
dégénère les chinois sont actuellement
les seuls compétiteurs que nous ayons
sur la science que nous faisons sont
tous en extrême-orient
c'est taiwan c'est la chine et la corée
du sud c'est eux qui ont actuellement si
vous voulez savoir une infection
respiratoire
les plus grandes séries du monde sont
toutes là ils ont pris une approche
extrêmement pragmatique extrêmement
moderne et nos concurrents c'est à
chaque fois je peux vous dire des choses
on essaie de faire actuellement offert
du séquençage direct d'infection du
cerveau une affection du coeur
on est tous contents parce qu'on a un
truc qu'on commence à écrire le papier
il ya un papier qui a été publiée avant
nous par des chinois dans un journal
dont vous avez jamais entendu parler
mais on est du coup on n'est pas les
premiers ça nous aide beaucoup
donc si vous voulez les chinois
actuellement ont une stratégie et que
moi j'ai vu et qui m'a relancé à un
moment où j'étais un peu découragé pour
y achètent quand j'ai vu ce qu'ils ont
fait à shanghai
et je vous assure fait une délégation
pour voir l'hôpital car à côté de
shanghai pour faire les maladies
infectieuses vous comprenez comment
voyez comment ils soignent je peux dire
c'est pas un truc vous regardez vous
voulez vous n'avez même pas je m'excuse
de dire ça mais vous n'avez même pas
l'équivalent en maladies infectieuses de
ce qui est actuellement au sénégal au
mali ou au congo ici d'accord au sénégal
si vous allez à côté de l'aéroport du
sénégal scheme ou aps
là je peux vous dire payer par gilead
d'ailleurs il ya un bâtiment
technologique dans lequel il ya un
niveau d'équipements de diagnostic et de
séquences qui est absolument inouïe
donc il ya une course technologique qui
s'est mise en avant dans lequel il ya
une partie civile qui n'a pas suivi et l
cette course technologique elle veut pas
s'endetter en ex en extrême orient pour
pour ce qui se passe en afrique chez lui
pourquoi je sais jamais je sais pas
prédire et deuxièmement je ne sais pas
pourquoi ce qui se passe en afrique
espace en afrique alors
il est possible que en tout cas c'est ce
que disent beaucoup d'africains qui ont
travaillé possible que le fait qu'ils
prennent de la chloroquine
systématiquement et joue un rôle dans la
diffusion de la maladie c'est possible
honnêtement j'en sais rien je miserais
pas là dessus c'est une constatation on
peut faire si on généralise à usage ou
pas c'est comme ça concernant l'anxiété
moi je veux bien répondre à ça ça
m'intéresse beaucoup il ya vous
admettrez que l'anxiété les pas de mon
côté g c'est pas moi qui affole les
populations non seulement jean paul pas
les populations mais qui plus est il n'y
a pas vraiment de raison d'être affolés
et depuis le début parce que je vous
conseille de regarder les données de
l'ined d'accord l'ined c'est l'institut
national de la démographie fait donc
venir quelqu'un de l'ined si vous voulez
et vous dire à quelle est actuellement
la perte d'espérance de vie pas la
mortalité parce que la mortalité à 85
ans c'est pas la mortalité des accidents
de la route
donc la perte d'espérance de vie n'est
pas la même quand vous avez une
polypathologies que vous avez un cancer
métastasé ou quand vous avez 92 ans
n'est pas la même que quand vous avez 18
ans et que vous avez un accident de moto
c'est pas le rêve d'accord donc ça se
calcule l'espérance de vie est la perte
d'espérance de vie actuellement calculé
pour 2020 comparé à 2019 et les deux 02
ans elle est inférieure à celle de la
perte d'espérance de vie de 2015
d'accord c'est ça la situation donc
c'est ça c'est énorme
anxiété monstrueux c'est pas moi qui la
développe un mois au contraire j'ai
toujours essayé d'être optimiste et au
contraire du côté se dire écoutez on
n'est pas face à un drame absolument
insupportable donc à la fin
là aussi c'est pour ça que c'est pas
maintenant que ça va se régler ça parte
dans un débat que ça s'est réglé ça va
se régler avec les chiffres et on verra
bien les chiffres et on verra bien les
chiffres donc moi je les vois maintenant
les chiffres je les suis je suis une
mère très précises parce que ça
m'intéresse je dis je suis empirique
donc ça m'intéresse de regard des
données chiffrées de les analyser les
comprendre et pourquoi la grippe qui a
tellement tu es dans l'année 2015 dont
on est fichu et pourquoi et qui a tué
plus que ce que ça va tuer installé sauf
s'il se passe des choses absolument
imprévisible pour moi pourquoi baisser
parce que d'un coup c'était la terreur
que tout le monde attendait que qui
allait arriver
c'est comme ça moi j'ai essayé là aussi
vous donner de les données comparatives
par rapport au désastre du passé c'est
pas le même désir pour une simple raison
c'est que effectivement c'est pas le
même c'est pas le même âge qui meurt
donc jeudi à 50% des gens qui y sont
morts qui avait plus de 85 ans et 72 %
je crois qu'ils avaient plus de 80 ans
et donc dans les pays européens
plus de 90 % avaient plus de 60 ans donc
ce qui s'est passé c'est tous les ans
les gens qui sont sur un équilibre
précaire les les circonstances font que
eh bien ces gens qui ont un équilibre
précaire tombe du côté du mauvais côté
des choses et donc c'est ça que nous
voyons essentiellement est là depuis les
épisodes ou jouets donnés tous les morts
qui sont produits depuis trois mois sur
ce ces données là voilà vous voyez donc
vous voyez les données d'âge
là c'est nous je vous dis le plus bleu
le mort le plus jeunes jusqu'à la côte
d'or avait 58 ans a malheureusement un
homme qui dort elle est absolument
épouvantable ok qu'est venue mourir qui
avait 54 ans qui a été refusée en
réanimation son état physiologique de
base était trop mauvais mais globalement
si vous voulez la perte et on n'a pas
calculé qu'il ya des calculs très
complet qui s'appelle les dalits qui
rajoute les polypathologies à l'âge mais
la perte de 2,2 d'espérance de vie va
être extrêmement mineure donc c'est pas
moi qui développe l'enquêté je les dis
encore la semaine dernière
donc c'est pas moi qui développe
l'anxiété donc le l'interdiction
préinscrire tout le monde c'est mon
opinion dessus si vous voulez mais là
encore je vois pas comment on aurait pu
avoir un débat serein quand en espace de
d'une demi journée
on sait le ministère et l'om est s'est
mis à dire on interdit partout hydroxy
chloroquine parce que ça tue les gens
pour un papier qui a été retiré trois
semaines après parce que c'était une
bande de pieds nickelés qui avait écrit
ce truc dont personne ne savait d'où il
sortait donc c'est pas moi qui raconte
des bêtises comme
au bout d'un moment il faut revenir sur
terre c'est pas moi un carcan des
bêtises qu'on puisse penser qu'on puisse
avoir la pensée que ce truc est vrai
quand on parle d'un médicament qui a été
donné à deux milliards d'habitants ça
veut dire qu'au bout d'un moment les
déconnexions des deux parties de son
cerveau qui en a une qui est devenue
guerrière et symbolique
et puis l'autre qui est resté
pragmatique ou pas mais c'est pas les
mêmes parties d'accord il ya quand même
pour réussir à vous faire avaler un truc
comme ça il en faut quand même je
m'excuse mais tout ceux qui ont cru un
truc pareil c'est quand même
spectaculaire et pourquoi les africains
se foutait de leur gueule quand même
c'est parce qu'ils sont en train de nous
dire qu'on est tous en train de mourir
alors moi de la chloroquine j'en bouffe
et à l'âge de deux ans en afrique on
avait ça sur la table tout le monde vous
fait son comprimé plus haut titre est
peut-être pour ça que je crains pas la
chloroquine donc le taux attendez je
vais tout marqué après qu'est ce qui
m'amuse 1 qu'est ce qui marche pas dans
notre système de santé la hausse il faut
regarder les données chiffrées ce que je
vous suggère il ya un truc qui est très
bien fait qu'ils appellent l cette
glande d'enquêté publié par l' ocde tous
les ans d'accord et c'est très bien il
faut regarder c'est pas moi donc le
chiffre faut les regarder et vous
regarderez quelles sont les différences
qu'il existe entre la france et les
autres pays en termes de mortalité en
termes de d'efforts financiers
donc il ya un effort financier
considérable de la france la france est
un des pays qui met le plus d'argent
possible de la santé mais c'est un de
ceux qui a le moins de médecins
tia les médecins les plus vieux et ça
c'est l'état qui a voulu ça la
limitation par le numerus clausus
pendant trente ans c'est pas ce
gouvernement c'est l'état qui a voulu ça
donc il a limité le nombre de médecins
d'une manière drastique
maintenant nous avons les médecins les
plus vieux d'europe c'est parti nous
avons pas assez de médecins
les médecins hospitaliers gagnent moins
d'argent
c'est pas le cas des universitaires
double salaire même bien notre vie mais
les médecins hospitaliers sont moins
bien payés en moyenne en france que
s'ils sont payés dans les autres pays de
l'osce et des oeufs de la moyenne de
l'oscd sommes d'accord
le niveau d'équipement en france est
inférieur à celui de la moyenne des pays
de l'osce et des eaux des grands
équipements d'accord et donc vous avez
la question vous avez la réponse
moi je veux pas débattre de sa non plus
il ya les chiffres il ya qu'à les
regarder c'est c'est vous
le télécharger sur internet s'appelle
human health and glanz tous les angles
ocde publiées les données chiffrées qui
leur sont transmises comme pour la
mortalité si vous voulez savoir la
mortalité vous regardez oromo je suis
désolé c'est un nom un peu ridicule
s'appelle oromo c'est toutes les données
de tous les pays européens de mortalité
au fil de l'eau
ok c'est suffit de les regarder est ce
qu'il manque quelque chose sur les
mutations donc vous avez des précisions
demandées par les mutations je viens sur
les virus à tous mute tout le temps
c'est comme ça à chaque fois on était
une mutation c'est lié au fait que vous
faites une copie de quelque chose quand
vous faites une copie ya des erreurs
d'accord mais les copies de l'adn
il ya assez peu d'erreurs en moyenne il
ya une erreur par millions de copies
donc sur un million de base
tgc dans la 1 million qui présentent une
mutation dans notre génome dans ceux des
bactéries ivre la rn là c'est un virus à
arn
il ya cent fois plus de mutations une
pour 10000 à peu près pour une pour 20
ou 30 mx a été estimée s'est estimée en
général et pour ce virus là ce estimé
être un pur donc ces mutations l'a
parfois sont des mutations dont on voit
pas pour l'apel synonyme c'est-à-dire
qu'elle n'entraîne pas un changement
d'acides aminés ce qui ne veut pas dire
qu'elle ne change pas des domaines de la
science actuelle c'est que parfois ça
change pas d'acides aminés mais ça
change la soie appelle la fitness et la
capacité de se multiplier du virus
parfois ça change un incident les
mutations qu'on a observé il y en a
quelques-unes qui se trouve dans la
protéine spike dont vous avez beaucoup
entendu parler et qui est une des
molécules qui fermement la spécificité
de ces gros navires us il ya des ddd
mutation qui se trouve dans la
nucléocapside c'est à dire dans le
premier entier et c'est les deux grands
antigènes si vous voulez que nous
reconnaissons quand on a une réponse
immunitaire c'est un la numéro unique et
au cap sic mais qui est qui et qui a
beaucoup de points communs avec tous les
autres coronavirus c'est pour ça qu'il
ya des réactions croisées peut-être dé
protection croisée
et puis la protéine spike qui est
relativement spécifiques
là aussi tentant dans lequel on a une
mutation donc ce que nous ont conté ce
qu'on regarde c'est le nombre de
mutations
sont survenues par rapport à virus
souche d'accord donc bien sûr il ya des
mutations mais globalement on avait
l'habitude qui est en moyenne 9 à 10
mutation par rapport au virus souche
pendant la première partie c'est à dire
qu'ils allaient dans les souches que
nous nous avons eu entre mars et mai
d'accord dans cette deuxième partie le
nombre de mutations par souche par
rapport à la mutation mer par rapport à
la souche mer et divo plus grande il ya
beaucoup plus de mutations que ce que
nous envoyons avant et ça il ya
plusieurs clauses qui sont comme ça
qu'ils ont donc une distance on mesure
la distance en regardant le nombre de
mutations par rapport à la souche
primaires si vous voulez donc ça veut
dire que la distance par rapport à ce
jeu primé avec plus importante
maintenant que ce qu'elle était merci
pour ces précisions va continuer et si
on d'être concis dans les questions et
les réponses néanmoins il ya une réponse
que vous n'avez pas fait c'est
concernant les préconisations du comité
scientifique qui n'était pas suivie par
le gouvernement si vous avez en quelques
mots quelque chose à dire pour répondre
à roger karoutchi
je me suis plus qu'elle était il ya eu
des vues quelques recommandations qui
n'ont pas été suivis on l'avait vu au
moment des écoles on l'a vu encore
dernièrement où il la question est
extrêmement sa mesure le conseil
scientifique affirme enfin firme est
normalement l'autorité de référence qui
donne des avis parfois le gouvernement
suive parfois le gouvernement ne suis
pas est ce que aujourd'hui l'existence
du conseil scientifique encore une vraie
valeur dans le débat rapidement je suis
d'accord pour le fait que le
gouvernement décide de suivre à suivre
parce que la responsabilité politique
mais on voit bien responsabilité
politique après donc la responsabilité
politique ses responsabilités politiques
c'est la responsabilité politique c'est
celui qui a la responsabilité qui décide
c'est comme ça que j'aurais chose après
il a des conseils que ces conseils
soient personnellement je n'étais pas
d'avis que les conseils du conseil
scientifique soit publique
je pense qu'il aurait dû avoir un
conseil
et du président ou un conseil des
ministres que ça se décide au tour des
ministres et que le ministre disent
écoutez voilà j'ai écouté voilà mon
opinion est que choses sortent comme ça
c'était mon avis et jusqu'à présent
c'est toujours comme ça que ça s'est
passé mais la composition du conseil
dans une partie qui était stratégique
à mon sens n'était pas bonne parce que
c'était le dérivé de reacting qui était
le groupe qui a été mis en place par
nice terme ça c'est mon opinion
alors on y va toujours le plus court
possible il nous reste un bon quart
d'heure petite angèle préville
merci monsieur le président donc mon
professeur j'ai d'abord une question qui
est qui vient à la suite de ce que vous
venez de nous dire sur la mutation du
virus donc il y à des mutations mais je
pense que dans l'inconscient collectif
on parle de mutation quand le virus
devient beaucoup plus dangereux pas on
sous-entend que alors est ce que dans
tous ces mutations est ce que dans l'eau
cure les occurrences vous voyez arriver
par les connaissances que vous avez qu à
un moment donné il risque de devenir
beaucoup plus virulent c'est à dire
beaucoup plus dangereux deuxième
question alors sur les essais alors vous
avez évoqué les raisons éthiques voire
morale qui font que vous n'avez pas
voulu avoir recours à des placebos parce
qu'on était en k2 dans une période de
crise avec une maladie très grave
puisqu'elle peut provoquer des décès
alors est ce que il vous semble
est ce qu'il ya des choses là dessus sur
le fait que quand on est en crise
on fait pas de décès visiblement parce
que effectivement les arguments que vous
avez peuvent s'entendre
et puis parce que on a souvent dit que
l'effet placebo c'est l homéopathie et
cetera donc pour des choses pour des de
la petite bobologie peut-être alors
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous dire sur
l'effet placebo parce que peut-être ce
serait intéressant de savoir après une
autre question
vous avez évoqué la création de centres
anti infectieux est ce que votre est-ce
que vous sous-entendez que votre
structure à marseille en est une
est ce qu'il y manque quelque chose
est-ce qu'il y en a d'autres sur le
territoire est ce qu'il ya des
équivalents ailleurs et est ce que vous
avez entendre été entendus par les
pouvoirs publics pour pouvoir après la
crise
développer des centres comme le vôtre je
regarde
j'évite guillotin oui merci monsieur le
président monsieur le professeur avant
toute chose je voudrais quand même
exprimé un regret effectivement de ne
pas pouvoir avoir avoir été auditionnée
sur un système de tables rondes et je
m'en suis exprimé auprès du président je
pense que ça aurait été à mon sens plus
éclairant puisque vous êtes un
scientifique qui parlait à des
scientifiques et ça nous aurait permis
de peut-être d'avoir eu des idées un peu
plus clair ensuite je voudrais rebondir
sur le tout début de vos propos vous
avez exprimé le fait de dire je ne
comprends pas je comprends pas ce qui
s'est passé pourquoi ça s'est emballée
médiatiquement quand j'ai parlé etc
c'est ce que vous avez dit au début de
vos propos liminaire c'est ça que je
parte pas voilà moi je voudrais vous
dire que je vais vous donner mon
expérience personnelle je vous dire que
je pense comprendre
moi je n'ai pas compris par contre le
premier matin ou en fait vous êtes
intervenu sur les ondes nom de radio où
vous avez affirmé à ce moment là
effectivement les faits positive la
chloroquine et avoir suscité un espoir
en fait important j'ai des habitants des
français qui étaient à ce moment-là
inquiet en pleine période d'épidémie est
dans une situation qu'elle une situation
quasi catastrophique de notre pays
donc votre vous faites votre expression
publique de votre statut de chercheur
reconnu et de renom a effectivement
suscité un grand espoir
or ne pensez vous pas qu'à ce moment là
alors vous n'êtes ni journaliste ni
politique vous êtes vraiment un
scientifique que l'on écoute reconnu et
sur lequel on pose en fait nos oreilles
et notre conviction
ne pensez vous pas que vos paroles à ce
moment là n'aurait pas dû peut être peut
être différée est ce que vous pensez pas
que les études auraient dû être un peu
plus avancé des résultats plus concrets
avant avant de douala d'aller confirmer
ou infirmer des choses comme ça qui ont
été prises chez une partie de nos
concitoyens
comme d'un peu d'argent comptant et je
pense que ça a été le début de la
fracture d'opinion dans notre pays est
un espèce de clan en fait dans ce pays
les pour et les contre le professeur à
août alors que le débat et je le conçois
n'est absolument pas là donc c'est un
petit peu est ce qu'il n'ya pas une
forme d' imprudence ou est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous pensé que c'était la
bonne solution et que vous
recommenceriez avec l'expérience ce même
cette même expression publique et après
j'avais deux autres questions mais ça a
été répondu pourquoi ne pas avoir fait
les études en double aveugle mais ça
rejoint la première est enfin là que la
question de la mutation est ce que la
mutation que vous exprimer en
laboratoire est une mutation clinique
avec plus grand plus de gravité ou au
contraire une gravité moins importante
et puis un changement de cible voilà
mais la question a été posée donc je
n'irai pas plus loin je vous remercie
merci merci céline boulay merci
messieurs le président j'étais vraiment
venu à cette audition m'a aussi pour
poser la question qui rejoint celle de
sujets vers millet de ma collègue à
l'instant qui était de dire que dit de
vous finalement cette sur médiatisation
et cet emballement médiatique
et qu'est ce que ça dit du débat
contradictoire en france et de la
démocratie sanitaire
vous avez partiellement répondu et
notamment répondu avec une certaine
modestie je le trouve en tout cas
personnellement tout au long de cette
audition en faisant l'apologie de
l'empirisme et en disant on attend un
peu on va comparer les chiffres et là on
verra qui aura raison il vous avait
parlé de pionnier en la matière en tout
cas puisqu'il s'agit souvent hors de nos
auditions de retour d'expérience je note
qu'il ya une grande confusion qui règne
dans la tête de nos compatriotes
français puisque en attendant les
chiffres est de savoir qui aura raison
le retour d'expérience qui était censée
rassurer tout le monde en disant on a
vécu une première crise majeure
on saura qui crée on saura gérer un
deuxième rebond pour l'instant créer
cette confusion est peut-être cette
inquiétude et on le voit quand on
interroge sur la mutation du virus en
fait on a des réponses qui sont
totalement contradictoires
donc moi j'ai maintenant 3 toute petite
question précise la première on a
beaucoup parlé donc de mutation du virus
mais est ce que vous seriez nous dire où
en est l'état de nos connaissances quant
aux malades qui ont été symptomatique
vous disiez très justement qu'au début
il y avait peu de faire de
dano semis et d'agouazi il y en a eu
beaucoup plus après est ce que ces
malades là peut avoir une évolution de
leurs séquelles
par exemple atteint avis ou durablement
dans leur père danos me aggasy ça c'est
une première car la deuxième je ne crois
pas que vous ayez répondu à notre
collègue rapporteur bernard jomier quand
vous avez dit de manière très forte dans
matière infectieuses il y avait une
destruction physique de l'organisation
des maladies infectieuses qui est à
l'origine de cette d'esprit destruction
et pourquoi
enfin rapide lorsque vous aviez été
interrogé récemment pour savoir ce que
vous pensiez du port du masque
généralisée vous avez répondu je ne fais
pas de politique
et vous avez une phrase tout à l'heure
que j'ai trouvé forte aussi en dix ans
et l'intendance qui suit la décision
or on en a parlé ce matin avec le comité
scientifique on a eu l'impression qu'au
début il y avait pas de port du masque
généralisée parce qu'il y avait pas de
masque maintenant il l'est parce qu'on
est des masques et je voulais savoir ce
que vous pensez de ça je vous remercie
olivier paccaud merci monsieur le
président professeur ce matin
effectivement les membres du conseil
scientifique comme l'a dit olivier henno
ont évoqué l'impréparation de notre
système médical pour faire face vous
même
ça vient d'être redit dans votre propos
liminaire vous avez pointé du doigt la
désorganisation voire la déstructuration
programmée entre guillemets de du
système de recherche épidémiologique de
recherche
est ce qu'en fait c'est pas plutôt une
combinaison des deux qui aboutit à ce
que l'on peut considérer quand même
comme une hécatombe alors les chiffres
sont plus ou moins variable
vous avez dit vous même tout à l'heure
que c'était peut-être pas si dramatique
que ça par rapport à aux résultats 2015
de la grippe de 2015 je suis pas sûr que
ça ne soit pas dramatique quand même par
contre ma question elle va traiter de
vous avez auquel le benchmarking les
résultats français sont loin d'être
brillant il ya pire il ya mieux
ce matin on avait eu quelques cas de
l'allemagne a quand même dit mouvement
mais il y a quelques jours dans cette
même nom ce même hémicycle nous avons
reçu les ambassadeurs
de corée du sud de taïwan et on a eu des
chiffres qui sont tout à fait éloquent
sept morts à taïwan 346 en corée du sud
alors ma question c'est on a vu ce
qu'ils ont fait à eux vous d'après vous
quand on veut éteindre un incendie
épidémiologique éviter qu'ils se
transforment en brasier
qu'est ce que l'on doit faire
immédiatement quand on a pas de vaccin
si monsieur le président à bas régime
universi mais simplement de questions
vous avez dit tout à l'heure c'est le
temps qui fait le tri et vous avez cité
beaucoup de papier c'est vrai que
vis-à-vis nous déjà mais je pense les
français c'est difficile quand même à
comprendre parce qu'on sait qu'il ya des
papiers vous en avez d'ailleurs vous
l'avez dénonce et qui sont
malheureusement publiés et qu'ils sont
faux et je pense que la confusion dont
pas se parler ma collègue est quand même
extrêmement importante et que même s'il
faut attendre le temps c'est vrai que la
science a quand même parlé sur un
certain nombre de choses et comme
bernard jomier et d'autres moi je
regrette qu'il n'y ait pas de
confrontation parce que comme on n'a pas
de confrontation entre chercheurs
on vous voit dans les médias les uns se
re pour les autres contre et c'est vrai
que ce matin on parlait peut-être au
lieu du conseil scientifique est
peut-être une agence dédiée aux crises
et pas seulement d'ailleurs avec des
scientifiques mais aussi avec des
chercheurs des sciences humaines et
sociales
et s'il y avait peut-être cette agence
en france peut-être que ça permettrait
aussi aux français de mieux comprendre
de moi avoir peur et je voudrais avoir
un peu votre avis là dessus et puis la
dernière la deuxième question
ça rejoint d'ailleurs mon collègue david
assouline c'est on n'a pas parlé du
vaccin
quelle est votre position aujourd'hui
sur le vaccin merci david assouline où
la question est posée par
je lui ai soufflé une question qui me
venait à l'esprit mais non j'ai deux
questions brèves
la première c'est je reste perplexe
parce que finalement la polémique qui a
fait connaître au grand public
votre non monsieur le professeur vous
étiez déjà très connue des milieux qui
devait l'être qui était professionnel
c'est votre traitement
je ne comprends pas que six mois après
on en reste à
il ya les pour et les contre moi je pose
la question
six mois après même quand ça n'a pas été
autorisé à la prescription
je connais du monde qui parce qu'il n'y
avait pas de traitement se sont rués est
une façon ou d'une autre vers ce
médicament il n'y a pas eu de résultats
aujourd'hui on ne vous avez fait vos
hôtes est sur une centaine de personnes
vous défendez qu' il y avait des
améliorations mais maintenant six mois
après c'est plus un débat il ya rien de
probant enfin je comprends pas ou sinon
qu'est ce que vous dites à monsieur
macron vous lui dites que il interdit et
à tous ces scientifiques à tous ces gens
notamment le comité scientifique qui
disent que ce n'est pas efficace faut
aller au bout
vous les accusez de refuser un
médicament qui empêcherait des cas de
s'aggraver de soigner des français c'est
cessa six mois après c'est pas un débat
des pour et des contres moi j'ai
beaucoup de critiques je suis critique
comme tout le monde
donc je prends je gobe pas tout ce que
nous dit le gouvernement les gens les
scientifiques
mais là à moins de me dire tiens coupe
l'eau qu'on veut que des français ne se
soigne pas et meurt je ne comprend pas
la nature du débat et ma conclusion aux
questions parce que la seule façon pour
moi de le comprendre c'est que derrière
le 6 ans
syfy que vous êtes est le pragmatique
que vous êtes il ya peut-être quelque
chose qui vient troubler c'est
l'idéologie
qu'avez-vous de commun pour faire
tribune commune bientôt avec monsieur
onfray philosophe
qu'avez-vous de commun à dire ou sur la
pandémie ou sur la société
je ne comprends pas merci gens seuls
excusez moi monsieur le président
monsieur le professeur
j'ai plusieurs questions comme
l'ensemble des français j'ai été
confinés que pensez-vous du confinement
automne mis en place dans notre pays
aurait-il pu être évité à l'instar
d'autres pays qui nous ont présenté
récemment mais leurs résultats
quel est votre avis sur la doctrine en
matière de masques qui s'est fait à
géométrie variable faut-il le
reconnaître qui est encore floue
aujourd'hui et dont certains remettent
en cause le degré de filtration dans
certains contextes
pensez vous que les moyens en matière de
recherche sont au rendez vous en france
je ne pense pas vous nous l'aviez déjà
exprimé lorsque nous vous nous avions
auditionnés vous savez cité l'exemple
tout à l'heure du nombre de scanners et
enfin est il possible selon vous de
raccourcir les délais pour réaliser les
tests aujourd'hui et surtout pour un
obtenir les résultats dans un délai
raisonnable merci merci avait coûté dix
minutes très bien et dix minutes pour
tout ça donc s'il vous plaît le premier
point qui est qu'elle soit placée volet
sport vous savez
c'est un vrai point c'est une occasion
que j'ai peut se discuter quelques fois
j'ai diffusé aussi alors il évite de
dire que c'est dramatique d'apporter de
l'espoir
je suis pas d'accord avec vous je pense
est dramatique d'apporter du désespoir
je le pensais je continue à le penser
je continuerai à le penser car et
l'effet placebo c'est effectivement
d'abord ça commence par apporter
l'espoir
donc il ya eu négligence de la
connaissance de l'effet placebo
scientifique sepehri fientes l'effet
placebo c'est un effet biologique que
l'on peut parfaitement noté avec les
moyens actuels de de radiologie qui
permet de voir qu'il ya des zones qui
sont éteintes ou qui sont ali mais quand
on vous savez quand on vous dit aux gens
qu'ils vont mourir on voit les zones
certaines dans le cerveau ça s'appelle
l'effet nocebo et donc quand on dit ça
tous les soirs à la télévision ce qu'on
fait on crée de l'effet nocebo qui est
visible radiologiquement quand on donne
de l'espoir aux gens y compris avec
l'effet placebo on voit les zones où ça
se fixe et ce à six deux problèmes en
droit commun zodiac épinière ça calme
les gens donc ça je m'excuse c'est de la
science encore la deuxième chose c'est
que effectivement je me souviens plus
qui pose la question on peut rebondir
dessus il ya une vraie question sur les
séquelles malheureusement on a commencé
à travailler dessus on a fait un papier
dessus qui est très impressionnant qui
montre que les zones où il ya des zones
qui ont un hypométabolisme derrière le
bulbe olfactif qui semble persister on
sait pas combien de temps elles vont
persister on sait pas ce qu'il décrira
et on sait pas ce qu'ils en protège mais
oui il ya des séquelles cérébrales
pendant un certain temps je sais pas
combien de temps plus que de séquelles
pulmonaires que l'on redoutait beaucoup
redoutaient beaucoup qui est beaucoup de
fibres hozjan a relativement peu mais il
y à des extinctions du métabolisme
cérébral qui est qu'on perçoit et on n'a
pas suffisamment de recul pour savoir
combien de temps ça va durer
le lead et j'y peux rien je vous leur
direz vous pensez vraiment que le
l'histoire de hydroxy chloroquine si
vous voulez et l'histoire de ce débat
est un débat franco français avec mon
milieu c'est parfait c'est simplement
pas vrai vous voyez ça dit si c'est pas
vrai c'est un débat mondial
vous vous rendez bien compte qu'on
comment vous pouvez penser qu'une bande
de polichinelle
publiés dans le new england journal
médecine et dans land 7 si on était pas
on n'avait pas perdu toute notion de
base pour publier des choses pareilles
qui ont été rétractées dans les trois
mois je n'ai jamais vu ça de toute
l'histoire le métier j'ai jamais vu ça
c'est pas moi qui ai fait ça c'est pas
moi qui ai déterminer sa donc arretez de
croire c'est une histoire
franco-française est un phénomène
beaucoup plus puissants que ça qui est
extrêmement qui est international qui
touche
il ya une partie qui a réagi d'une
certaine manière qui est l'europe de
l'ouest et une partie des états unis qui
a d'ailleurs les plus mauvais chiffres
mondiaux de gestion de la crise qui a
géré d'une certaine manière en courant
après deux molécules nouvelles fait à
nouveau par des laboratoires qui
maintenant cours d'une certaine entre
manière après après la vaccination il ya
une autre partie qui était une partie de
gestion extrêmement pragmatique y
compris si vous avez vu les coréens
c'est un pragmatisme qui est totale donc
il y as we une manière pragmatique de
gérer chose qui est de détecter d'isoler
il ya des gens qui a des pays dans
lequel on a réquisitionné des hôtels
pour y mettre les gens qui étaient
positifs tant qu'il était positif de
manière à faire ce qu'on faisait avant
avec le lazaret et non pas faire ce
qu'on a fait avec le confinement qui est
la quarantaine donc c'est des natures
différentes ce qui s'est passé dans la
destruction et la direction je suis
d'accord que ça n'a pas été volontaire
il s'est trouvé que il ya eu une époque
qui est une époque paradoxale qui était
juste avant l'épidémie de sida les gens
disaient maladies infectieuses c'est
terminé
donc il y avait à paris à l'hôpital
claude bernard les gens ont travaillé
sur les maladies infectieuses et assez
de manière assez extraordinaire c'est au
moment où le sida est arrivé on a fermé
claude dard fermer l'endroit dans lequel
on pouvait investir massivement pour
pouvoir lutter contre les nouvelles
épidémies qui arrive et ça a été la pire
épidémie du 20e siècle et donc il ya une
vraie il ya une vraie question de remise
en cause est ce que vous vous considérez
comme est incompréhensible moi je
comprends bien c'est que quand les gens
ont pris prochains mois y compris
d'ailleurs ont pris une direction c'est
très très difficile de sortir du sentier
dans lequel on est rentré c'est très
compliqué de dire écoutez on s'est
trompé finalement c'est pas comme ça
qu'il fallait faire c'est compliqué pour
chacun d'entre nous mais c'est compliqué
pour le ministre c'est compliqué pour le
président la république c'est compliqué
pour delfraissy et ses prolongements
compliqué pour moi même si je suis pas
lucide de ce point
là parce que je le vends pas donc cesser
c'est pas encore une fois c'est ce qui
s'est passé et quand vous me dites et
détient comment ça se traduit moi je
trouve étonnant que ce soit que les
consignes de maladies infectieuses dans
l'assistance publique de paris soit
donnée par le directeur sens unique de
paris voir ça ils veulent les consignes
de maladies physiques ne sont pas donnés
par le dg de sang celui de marseille
donc c est je peux vous dire que quand
j'étais jeune c'était un titulaire de
chaire de maladies infectieuses c'est
lui qui disent il ajouté ça qu'il faut
faire
c'était pas le dg de l'assistance de
paris cécile c'est étrange non enfin
j'en sais rien c'est un truc de
professionnels la médecine je m'excuse
donc il y a une vraie question moi je
vous dis ce que je pense je pensais moi
je pensais qu'il va aller faire un
affectio paul necker pasteur je l'écris
en 2003 à mai à necker à pasteur faire
un bâtiment pour les mavericks 2 à
necker soit juste à côté de pasteur que
les gens travaillent qui a une antenne
de la nds émanant santé publique et là
il y aurait quelque chose qui pourrait
avoir une taille mondiale où il y aurait
des interlocuteurs soient capables de
tout faire ça c'était raisonnable
c'est ce que je pensais à l'époque et je
pense encore maintenant peut-être parce
que je suis incapable de changer d'avis
c'est possible est ce que j'ai oublié
quelque chose vous posez la question de
dudu du confinement et du masque cetc
des questions sur qui sont extrêmement
occupés extrêmement difficile de
répondre
il ya des gens qui commencent à étudier
ça à faire des études comparatives et
même ses études comparatives elles sont
difficiles à analyser parce que les
comportements sociaux dans les
différents pays sont pas les mêmes donc
le comportement social en italie et en
suède sait pas exactement même en
particulier dans les contacts sociaux
sont pas les mêmes et donc de comparer
l'effet du confinement sur l'efficacité
des mesures c'est quelque chose qui est
très complexe et moi je pensais donc
c'est ce que j'ai dit quand j'ai
rencontré le président je lui ai dit moi
il faut prendre je pense que le rôle du
politique c'est prend toutes les mesures
pour éviter l'affolement la peur la peur
est terrible il faut éviter l'affolement
mais si
ça donne l'effet inverse si vous voulez
alors c'est pas fonctionnel parce que le
confinement ça ça a été analysé en
italie en espagne sur des milliers de
tests de donneurs de sang 1
le confinement n'a pas protégé les gens
individuellement du risque d'infection
c'est à dire que les gens qui n'étaient
pas pour des raisons professionnelles à
part le métier de santé qui n'était pas
confinée tu es plutôt moins positif que
les gens qu'on finit donc ya pas de
substrats scientifique individuel ce qui
ne veut pas dire que ce ne soit pas un
choix de société un moment donné de dire
écoutez plutôt que tout le monde soit
folle et s'inquiète émigrent si vous
voulez il vaut mieux les confiner donc
je ne sais pas répondre à ça et pour le
masquer
c'est pareil c'est pas une vérité
scientifique brutale il ya une vérité
scientifique brutale c'est que quand
vous êtes dans le personnel de soins
canton étant donné qu'on est à 30 40
centimètres des gens le risque de
contamination est plus important c'est
évident ça a été il a été démontré que
le masque de diminuer dans ces
conditions dans les autres conditions ça
n'a pas été démontrée ça peut pas l'être
donc c'est une question là aussi le
message social est-ce que ce message
social est utile je n'ai pas d'avis que
je dirais plutôt oui si vous voulez je
sais pas s'il faut être extrêmement
punitifs sur quelque chose comme ça mais
je dirais que le fait de porter un
masque si ça empêche les gens de
s'embrasser et quand ils se voient ou si
ça leur permet de se faire se rappeler
qu'il ya quelque chose qui circule c'est
c'est pas on peut penser que c'est
raisonnable
voilà donc deux de permettre de
conserver une distance sociale sans se
faire d'énormes illusions sur le pouvoir
c'est les mains il faut faire attention
il faut passer dix fois vingt fois
l'alcool sur les mêmes par jour ça c'est
vraiment c'est les mains qui sont la clé
mais si ce message là permet de changer
les comportements
pendant cette période là je pense que
c'est intelligent et quant aux mutations
jour accéder à la question mi temps je
m'excuse si mutants dans votre dans
notre esprit ça veut dire plus méchant
je l'avais dit c'était plus méchant hein
les mutants ça veut dire que ça change
on a plutôt l'impression que les mutants
vont à sonder forme dégradée de la forme
initiale
c'est plutôt notre impression français
c'est très compliqué de deviner pouvoir
pathogène d'un virus en voyant sa
séquence personnes certainement faire
mais globalement nous c'est ce ca 12
appareils plutôt lié à des formes qui
sont mon gars tu aussi sur les une
régulation un peu de la parole
scientifique jeu mais mais mais mais
mais encore une fois je m'excuse de
france mais je veux d'abord je vous
appartient pas c'est à dire que ma
parole scientifique d'une parole libre
qui est garantie par la constitution et
par l'histoire du pays et elle s'adresse
d'une quantité de gens dans le monde
vous pensez que ce que j'ai dit est plus
conséquent seule la la prescription de
dix ans que c'est que l'origine des hits
robin vous vous trompez très très
lourdement
il ya un institut de sondage qui sont de
tous les médecins du monde pour leur
savoir quels sont pour leur demander
quels sont les médicaments qu'ils
prescrivent dans le vide
je peux vous allez dire que ça il ya une
une influence sur intervenus en nombre
de gens qui considèrent que c'est une
thérapeutique est essentiel qu'ils
étaient qui est énorme
vous verrez bien avec le temps pour
l'instant encore une fois c'est pas moi
qui racontait les balivernes sur la sur
la toxicité d'un médicament est prescrit
chez deux millions de personnes je
raconte pas de balivernes on verra bien
vous verrez bien pour l'instant c'est
les dossiers et les les
les publications sur l'usagé des drogues
cycle enquiquinante que ça ça diminue
dans 30 et 50 % la mortalité sont en
train de s'accumuler pourrait bien vous
n'avez pas de sortir il en sort tous les
jours vous verrez c est ce qui concerne
la question de jean sol oui il manque
des scanners notamment le aux doses où
l'avait dit et on le partage on a déjà
eu l'occasion catherine déroché temps
particulièrement attentives à ce sujet
là d'en parler lors notamment des pelles
fss quant aux délais de test
effectivement on constate que iad et
nous on en parle de stratégie devrait
peut-être évoluer écoutez nous on n'a
pas de problème de des lieux de test le
délai moyen de rendu chez nous ces huit
heures il n'y a pas de tests qui se sont
rendus en plus de 24 heures
pardon
moi si c'est qu'ils ont des machines en
effet qu'on des résultats très rapides
mais tout le monde ne les a pas les
laboratoires d'analysés auquel le lambda
dans lequel on va n'a pas ce type de
machine mais je m'excuse mais
globalement pour pau pour clore puisque
c'est une question qui m'a été posée
c'est pourquoi finalement ces approches
ne se réconcilie pas des gens qu'à venir
voir ce qu'on fait des tests et soixante
dix neuf mille personnes sont qu'à venir
voir ce qu'on fait je vous signale comme
ministre est passé à marseille il n'est
même pas venu gardez donc c'est pas moi
qui penche vers la personne et en
particulier je suis républicain donc je
respecte les gens qui sont aux affaires
je vous dis encore une fois nous et je
publie les chiffres de ce que nous
faisons régulièrement et toutes les
semaines écoutez ça s'appelle le
benchmarking ça aussi si vous savoir
comment on fait il faut venir voir
moi je refuse personne d'aucun parti de
personnes ça m'est égal et quant à
discuter avec les ans je discute avec
tous les gens intelligents quel que soit
leur bord merci merci bien
bah écoutez on va on va clore ce débat
en attendant le suivant en vous
remerciant ya pas eu de confrontation
mais il ya eu des échanges frontaux ce
qui était important merci